Okay.
Hey everybody,
what's up?
How are Ya?
I don't eat too many people to answer,
but,
uh,
this episode of the Joe Rogan experience
podcast is brought to you by Ting Ting
is a cell phone company that we've had
sponsor our podcasts for quite a while
and we've had nothing
but positive reviews.
I think that's one of the most important
things about when you have a podcast.
I mean,
what,
what did,
what does a podcast,
just people talking and having a
conversation and talking about shit.
It's entertainment whenever it is.
If you have an add on it,
it gets really tricky.
Like you have to make sure
that whatever you're using,
whatever you're endorsing,
it's gotta be legit.
And,
uh,
one of the nicest things is when you have
a podcast sponsor and you get positive
feedback.
So I thank you for that
feedback and I don't,
I even the negative stuff,
I don't mind it.
It's important this having this open
loop like that with people is huge.
Everyone that I've turned on a Tang
has said that it saved the money.
So what Tim does is they
use this sprint backbone,
excuse me.
So they have a really good cell phone
network and then they do it their way.
They do it without contracts.
They deal,
you can cancel at anytime.
It's a mobile company that makes sense.
A No B s mobile company,
they don't have early termination fees.
They don't have bundling.
No bullshit.
Really simple.
You pay for what you use.
It's cheap.
98% of people would save
money if they use Tang.
That's legit.
Um,
Chris Ryan,
who's a good friend and I'm doing him
and Duncan Trussell are an eye or doing a
podcast tomorrow together.
Chris a switched over to
Tang and he fucking loves it.
He was like,
because it's so much cheaper.
Red Vans switched over and saved a
shitload of money when he was in Canada.
It's a sweet,
sweet,
sweet cell phone company and you could
save 25 bucks if you go to rogan.ting.com
save 25 bucks off.
They're super sweet android phones.
They use all the top of the line.
Android phones,
like the HTC one,
the Samsung Galaxy note.
The note three is,
what's the one?
The one that I have the uh,
s for all really sweet devices.
Uh,
you missed nothing.
rogan.ting.com we're also
brought to you by hover.
Hover is a domain name company.
It's actually the domain
name company that I use.
They have an awesome online interface.
It's super intuitive,
really easy to use and it's a,
it's owned by the same people that own
Tang and they have the same sort of
philosophy,
give people a good product
and don't rip them off.
It's possible like you can have a,
a frictionless relationship between the
people who have things like hover and
the people who need things like us.
And if you're looking for a domain name,
you look into register,
don't domain name you,
you cannot do better than hover.
They also have free who
is domain name privacy,
which it should be.
I mean that should be standard
but it was in the beginning.
However,
make sure it is awesome website and
again by the same people that run ting,
I have my stuff registered there and
if you need to register anything there,
they also can set it up for you.
We can move domain names if you have
it registered somewhere else and you're
like,
I don't like what these people do or
you got to put on some mailing lists or
some crazy shit thing happened.
Things happen folks.
But Hover always been there for me.
Uh,
I've,
I've enjoyed hover for a long time.
Um,
we have new promo codes for
Heather for hover for this episode.
So we're going to have different
ones for different episodes.
I guess the trying to figure out like
which episodes were more effective.
Target Marketing,
ladies and gentlemen for this episode,
it's the word powerful.
So go and use the word powerful
and save some money at hover.
Again,
I endorse him,
I use him and as I endorsed Tang,
same cell phone company or same company
that owns a cell phone company also owns
hover.
Uh,
you can try 30 days of Google apps
on your domain for free at hover.
And see if you like it.
There's a lot of really
cool things about hover.
Go check it out,
be one with it and use
the code word powerful who
do much coffee.
We're also brought to you by Onnit Dotcom.
Com Gentlemen.
Yeah,
that's right on it.
If you haven't been there for a while.
We've got a lot of cool things.
Um,
like uh,
we have digestive enzymes that we
started selling and Dr. Gordon,
I'm sure knows all about this stuff.
Strength and conditioning equipment.
Essentially what ANA is,
the way we describe it is a
human optimization website.
We want to give you the tools to
optimize the way your body functions,
the way your brain works,
your,
your cardiovascular endurance,
your strength,
your explosive power.
Mark Gordon,
who know what I'm saying,
man.
Uh,
we sell cattle bells,
battle ropes,
all that kind of good shit.
Protein powder made from the finest hemp.
All of it is at [inaudible]
dot com browse around.
There's a lot of shit to look out there.
And the code word is Rogan.
If you use that code word,
you will save 10% off
any and all supplements.
All right,
your fucks,
Dr. Mark Gordon is here and we're
to learn some shit about life.
So cue the music,
the Joe Rogan experience,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
My friend
this ladies and gentlemen,
this is my friend.
When
Dr. Mark Gordon and Mark Gordon is a,
you're not just a doctor.
You're a fascinating dude.
And uh,
when I first met you,
one of the first things I said was like,
this motherfucker needs his own
podcast because you can just talk,
nobody can spit out information.
Like I've never,
I've,
I've been alive for 46 years.
Never met a guy who can spit out as
much impressive information as you that
quickly,
when it comes to like the body,
it's my escape at home.
I have four women.
So who gets to talk at home,
right?
Not me.
Yeah.
It's so outside the world.
I get to share what I do
inside.
You get shutdown,
I get shut down.
Wow.
But you have a lot of information,
dude.
Every time I talked to you,
I wish I had like a notebook or what show
was recording it because I always try
to remember as much as possible.
And you've given me some great
advice as far as you know,
health and fitness and exercise and all
sorts of different things that you know
about.
But I always walk away
from every conversation,
you know,
I know I forgot something.
I know I didn't remember something
like the last time we were talking,
you were telling me about some shit that
helps your liver after you drank and
you take this,
what is this?
What is it?
Unbelievable.
Glutathione pulled that thing closer
to your face so people hear you better.
Glutathione,
glutathione and that,
that,
that helps your liver
when you drink alcohol.
Well it helps you with just about
anything that delivers responsible for,
um,
digesting or metabolizing as
you metabolize certain drugs,
chemicals and so forth.
The liver uses up its ability to,
um,
continue the process so it spills over
into the blood and that's how you get,
uh,
you know,
drunk because your liver can
only deal with a certain amount.
So if you replenish or replace
the glutathione in the liver,
you get an incredible benefits of it.
Not only does it help with metabolism,
but it's an incredible antioxidant for
the brain and for the eyes and for the
heart.
What does it made out of?
It's three amino acids that are together.
It's in our body,
but we don't have enough of it to really
generate the metabolism that we need if
we're drinking.
And where do they get that?
Where did they get glued at time?
Cause I know Dave Asprey
really into that stuff too.
The version of it's manufactured,
but how do they make it,
what is it?
Oh,
it's three amino acids that
they've put together and um,
the products that we interact with our,
um,
it's a delivery technology.
We're you wrap the vitamins or your wrap,
the supplement in a what's
called the Lyposomal,
which is like a cell wall from lecithin
is from soy and it protects whatever it
is that you're ingesting because
a lot of the things that you take,
like I think I shared with you,
if you take a thousand
milligrams of vitamin C by mouth,
you only absorb 19% the rest of it is
destroyed by the acid that's in the
stomach.
But if you wrap it in this
protection called the light basalt,
you'll be able to absorb 93% so
taking something like glutathione,
which normally when you take
it in in its natural form,
it's destroyed.
Most of it is destroyed and then absorbed
and then re manufactured in the blood.
But if you wrap it in this
protective outer coating,
it Lyposomal,
you can absorb it more readily and
their effects are unbelievably positive.
For instance,
a gentleman who uh,
went out drinking three high balls
and five shots of Tequila went home in
subsequently was very dizzy,
nauseous.
He forgot that I gave them a sample of
this gludethyon in east used four puffs
under the tongue,
held it for 30 seconds
and then 30 minutes later,
clear as a bell.
Woke up the next day,
went out partying again.
Couldn't get drunk.
Wow.
That sounds like nonsense.
It isn't nine.
So wish
I was smart enough to
call you on your bullshit.
I talked to my office.
Erin will tell you everything.
That sounds crazy.
Maybe that guy was lying.
Maybe it wasn't that drunk drugs.
If I told you who it was,
you would know.
He's a hammer.
Hammer fist.
He knows how to throw him down.
He knows how to throw him down while
you're giving people some false hope,
man.
You tell him,
take glue to tie on and don't
worry about the drinking.
Well,
no,
everything in moderation.
But if you go across that line,
you need to have something
to fall back onto.
I need to try that now,
but I don't want to get drunk enough
to try it and I'm scared to get drunk
enough to try it.
But,
but it sounds like a strange thing to try.
You know,
for years,
you know,
I take the kids to Mexico every year and
I take a bottle of Scotch with me and I
sit and read a book and drink to Scotch
over a period of a couple hours and I
turn the bottles empty.
My kids go and get you some
mosquitoes and I continued drinking.
I don't get drunk.
It turned out that one of the products
that I was taking had a very high amount
of reduced glutathione in it.
So when I got exposed to
the glutathione world,
which was just last year with
a doctor Christopher shade,
who's one of the gurus in
the area of Glutathione,
a technology and absorption,
um,
he introduced it to me and it made
sense reading the literature on how it
functions in the liver.
That's pretty fascinating.
There's also the
dehydration that comes from,
from alcohol consumption.
What's the mechanism behind that?
Alcohol's a diuretic.
It causes you to go to the bathroom and
since you used all those colorful words
earlier,
I'll use the word,
it makes you pee,
right?
Of course.
You mean like bad words?
I use bad.
Come on.
I was going to interrupt you and say,
you can say those words on this,
just the Internet.
Well,
it shouldn't be that way.
I mean,
if you and I were sitting down
just having a conversation,
we would talk like to normal people.
It's not,
we're not vulgar,
awful people,
but occasionally the word
fuck is the right word.
Absolutely.
It's the right word.
In about every tense of
the English language.
We robbed of that freedom by television
because people were pretending by not
saying fuck on television,
that people don't say fucking real life.
So you're never going to really
believe what you see on television.
There's always going to be this bridge
that you're not willing to cross over
because these people never swear.
It's silly where the same people,
we're all the same people.
People that say fuck to people that
don't say you don't like to say it.
Don't say it,
but it's not a big deal.
Thank you,
George Carlin.
Jesus Christ.
It should have been figured
out a long time ago,
but it's not.
So yeah,
you could say,
find your retentive.
Well,
I use words like anal
retentive instead of assholes.
You know,
that's not a good word.
It isn't.
Okay,
fine.
We're dead to me is a
totally different thing.
Culberson and ass off.
They're just fucking like
to clean their hands anyway.
Alcohol has a couple
of things that it does.
Alcohol is a sugar.
So what happens is it causes your blood
sugar to go up and then drop because
insulin's turned on and you
become irritable because
you need sugar to run the
brain.
Uh,
and then dehydration,
you need hydration.
Is that why people get
hungry for pancakes?
Maple Syrup.
You want that syrup,
butter and Maple Syrup
and the Morgan carbs.
The better brain food.
Brain food.
Yeah.
The more carbs the better for
the brain after you drink.
Right?
It's a diuretic.
It's a dehydrator and it's a
hypoglycemic drops your blood sugar.
It's an Amino suppressant too,
right?
It is itch actually.
It shuts off growth hormone production.
Yeah.
It's not good,
but damn.
Why does it make things so fun?
I know.
It's what a crazy thing.
Something that makes us so happy for a
little while just to sell fucking and so
stupid and dangerous and
impossible to control.
Like that's the craziest
thing about the alcohol.
It's like it's impossible
to regulate how many people,
you just put it out in the market and
people drink whatever they want and if
they,
it's not a lot.
You drink a glass like this
whiskey and you're fucked.
What other thing do you have the,
you could just buy like that that like
literally will kill you if you drink too
much and you can get it everywhere.
It's pretty ridiculous.
Yeah,
it's unbelievable.
If you really stop and think about it,
I think what's even worse is the fact
that they've restricted marijuana use for
so many years.
When you look at the stats on
people who cause accidents,
I mean you're only saying this because
you didn't watch Nancy Gracie's piece
last night.
No,
I definitely saw Nancy
Grace's speech last night.
You would understand that Ma
out marijuana makes you lazy.
Oh you it makes you fat.
I've seen that and it makes you just
want to sit on the couch and eat chips.
That's what Nancy grace says.
One out of 300 so bad.
That poor sweetie.
She needs a pot cookie.
Just one of those pot
cookies and met you just go,
oh,
why was I fighting this while
some of them be like rubber feet.
If she could just sit back on a really
comfy couch after a pod cookie and some
dude was really good at it,
rubbed her feet,
she'd be like,
why was I saying that?
This is bad.
I'm going to take my shoes off now.
Yeah,
Porn Nancy,
she needs a hug.
A lot of people are angry at her.
Not me did she needs some love.
She's crazy.
She's talking nonsense about wheat,
Europe,
big fat lady.
And you're talking
about people being lazy.
That doesn't make any sense at all.
And I know she's not lazy.
I mean,
she's a,
she was a judge.
She,
you know,
was running this TV,
this TV show forever.
Being on TV shows the hard work being
on a successful TV show for a long time.
That's hard fucking work,
but come on,
you're talking crazy about weed.
No one's listening to you.
That's nonsense.
You're the exact thing that
young kids want to avoid.
They want to avoid an angry,
Yeley preachy person on television who's
yelling at them and telling them some
shit that they know is not true.
It doesn't make you lazy.
If you're lazy,
you're already fucking lazy.
It has nothing to do with a weed,
but don't you think the kids nowadays,
they look,
they listened to that and
they say interesting and
they just do their own thing.
They know it's a bunch of shit.
I think she's just had a touch.
She's completely out
of touch and it's not,
not just that a touch foolishly ignorant
as to the consequences of what she's
saying,
because people were just going to,
if you really believe what you're saying,
you're doing it such a foolish way that
people are gonna immediately discredit
the message because it's coming from you.
The marrow ball numb makes you lazy.
Say No,
it doesn't stop it,
dummy.
That's a ridiculous statement.
Yeah.
And she's only saying
it because she's just,
she's just,
you know,
miss the boat.
She missed,
missed the Internet.
I think Colorado,
Washington,
and eventually Arizona will be great
test areas to disprove all that bullshit
that's being said about marijuana.
Do you know what they're doing though?
It's really sneaky thing.
The Colorado dispensaries,
they have dispensary's that
they've had for a long time.
They had them back when I lived there,
but they have actual retail stores,
but they're not allowed
to have bank accounts.
So they have massive amounts of cash and
the government literally will not let
them put it in a federal bank.
They can't put it in a state bank.
They can't put it,
they can't put it in a bank.
They don't allow them
to put their business.
So they gotta they gotta have a safe
somewhere and put stacks of fucking paper
money.
Is this,
you gotta remember to count it or
like what are you talking about?
This is the stupidest idea ever.
You,
you can make money,
but you can't put it in a bank.
Here's even worse.
You probably heard about in
Denver where they have um,
uh,
outlets for picking up marijuana but you,
there's no place legally
designated to spoke it.
That's hilarious too.
Yeah.
They even have the sniff machines.
Have you ever seen him?
They put on,
they've developed these things to pick
out nanoparticles in the air and they put
it over their nose.
Like you're watching a fucking movie.
They're sniffing to smell.
If they could smell marijuana
from your home outside your home,
and if they can,
they will give you a ticket.
It's a new way to make
money with a giant electric.
It looks like a cartoon knows this
guy's got like a space knows on.
Have you seen it?
No,
I haven't seen it.
Well,
Jamie pope pull a picture.
That shit up.
It's hilarious.
Called the sniffer.
I don't know what the fucking
technical name for it is,
but they're literally standing outside
of people's houses trying to smell weed.
You made we legal coordinates in there.
We can't have a backyard party.
You can't pass around a joint,
the backyard or you go
have to get a ticket.
Come on.
Assholes.
That's ridiculous.
What's the big deal?
It smells good.
It's awesome.
Smells good.
It just does like there's some things
that don't smell good when they're burning
like cigarettes,
smell like shit.
You have hemp oil was legal.
I'd be using it on what?
On my body?
Well,
it is legal.
You can get hemp oil.
What do you mean you get detoxified him,
boy.
No,
because hemp,
hemp oil doesn't
necessarily have THC in it.
It's not necessarily psychoactive.
It depends on whether it comes from the
hemp plant or whether it comes from the
female though the marijuana,
the marijuana is not even a real word.
Marijuana is the slang for
a Mexican wild tobacco.
That's where that word came from.
When the a whole Henry,
Harry Anslinger and
William Randolph Hearst,
when they were trying to
make marijuana illegal,
that's what they started calling it.
They couldn't call it cannabis.
There's the,
uh,
there's a thing and when
they made it illegal,
half the people in Congress didn't even
realize that they had made marijuana
illegal.
Look at that.
Notice the electronic nose.
It's got a compass on the end of it
and shit to tell you where the smoke is
coming from.
This is so stupid.
Look at that.
That's a giant electric piggy.
It's a pig with the electric piggy.
That's what that is.
And by the way,
you're a pig if that's what you do.
If you stand in front of people's houses
with a fucking electronic sniffer,
not even your own nose,
you're a pig.
You're trying to arrest them because
they're smoking something that's now legal
inside their house,
but they left a window open.
You're a pig.
That's a pig.
So disgusting.
I love techno.
Electronic.
Fucking fake knows
the guy who made that must have
been laughing like a mother fucker.
He was probably so high when he,
when he's so into that pat and he
didn't even realize he fucked us.
Me and he's one of us and he fucked us
with his stupid electric robot knows,
but he made lots of money
so he can go to Colorado,
have his own condo and smoke all day.
The irony and manage if he'd just started
his own pot selling business after he
sold those things.
Imagine if he was like the bank's
betting against themselves.
Hey,
we all need a cash cow.
That's the move.
That's what you do.
You,
you develop,
you develop shit to help the cops while,
while profiting off weed
and it all eats itself.
Yeah.
It is legal to smoke marijuana on your
front porch and voted for last month.
10.
Okay,
good.
Yeah.
You could smoke on your front porch now.
Powerful Denver.
Wow.
Fuck yeah.
Denver Denver's Straw.
But there's gonna be a lot of
blow back from all of this.
And the first blow back that we're
seeing is the blow back and his era has
housing are doing it.
Hey Mike.
The A,
the first blow back is the bank thing.
They're not allowed to
put their money in banks.
So what they supposed to do,
they have to fucking stash money places.
Man.
It's really crazy.
He's going to have to buy cash houses
and shit and cash boats and maybe that's
the point.
Yeah,
they're trying to get it
so they can't get rich,
which I'm all for it,
man.
You know,
I think that if people,
if people want marijuana,
they should be able to grow
it and it's not hard to grow,
you know?
And I think that one of the reasons why
it's so expensive and been so expensive
for so long is because it's illegal.
Once it becomes legal,
you know,
it,
it should like all balance out.
It should,
it should be really easy to
get super easy to access,
easy to grow.
You don't really need to pay for it.
It's just the,
this,
the fear of having,
you know,
uh,
somebody come and find your
little collective that you
and your buddies have set
up on some little piece
of property somewhere.
Oh,
they'd been doing that up north.
Yeah.
They've been busting houses,
million dollar houses
with the entire basement.
First floor,
second floor with all the hydroponics.
Yeah.
They go by your house with a special
machine now and it checks like the amount
of electrical,
whatever the fuck is
going on in your house.
So if you have like a lot of lights on,
they might just storm your house.
There was a,
an old couple that were,
I believe there is a
former FBI or former CIA,
and they got arrested.
The fucking,
the DEA arrested them came into their
house because they thought they had to
grow up when they were
just growing vegetables.
So they broke,
I mean,
they literally went,
if I forget whether it
was a former FBI or CIA,
I forget who it was,
but the DEA literally went into their
fucking house because they thought they
were growing marijuana.
And you know,
like Jesus Christ,
guys like,
do you not check who the
fuck these people are?
No.
Okay.
Can I go in there and get those plants?
But I wish I remember the,
the exact specifics of the story.
But it was hilarious.
Denver though,
they don't give a fuck.
They said,
come get us.
It's right.
We're cowboys.
We've got fucking ranches up here.
We've got wells,
we got water wells.
I think we're good.
I think we're gonna keep our weed now
and it's all this fucking crazy blowback.
Crazy blowback.
Well,
I'm expecting to Chinese to come here.
They just dropped four point $7 billion
into the American economy buying
businesses.
Let's see if they go to Colorado
and buy some weed farms,
they're going to do it.
Chinese,
they're going to go off.
You'll right couch.
Yeah.
Can you imagine how much the world would
change if Chinese people came over here
and started growing weed?
They're very ambitious folks.
It would be over real quick.
We've got a lot of money
these days too much.
It's a fascinating thing,
isn't it?
How um,
these nations look at
each other over time.
You know,
the,
the sort of,
the character of the nation sort of
shifts back and forth and now China,
the character is become instead of
one of just total communism of this,
you know,
rampant capitalism and this,
this,
this new feeling of China being like,
you know,
producing literally
every fucking cell phone.
No one demand except for the Samsung ones,
which are pretty in Korea and he all the
top cell phones and laptops and shit.
China is just make it so much shit.
Yeah.
Lenovo bought IBM thinkpad and it's now
the number one business computer in the
world under the name of the Nova.
Wow.
Yeah.
I work in China.
I have a contract and trying to,
with the second wealthiest guy in China
for wellness centers and I'm watching
what he's buying up.
Unbelievable.
The amount of money that the dumping here,
I bought a thinkpad just
because I'm dumb and I figured
that will be the way to really
inspire me to be less dumb.
Every time I do some
writing on my think pad,
you know he can't write total
nonsense when you have a think pad,
you know it's too pretentious,
but I liked that little nipple man.
Nobody ever stuck with that nipple.
The nipple for the mouse?
Yeah.
The nipple for the mouse
is pretty sweet man.
I don't know why it never caught on they,
they nailed that shit with IBM.
A couple of other like PC
laptops had that little nipple.
Yeah,
that's my baby.
I had one of those.
I think it was the shit I
was riding on Saint Pat's on.
I'm obviously thinking
you were just playing
with that little redness.
Well,
I wasn't playing with it.
I was working.
That's what I was going to work.
There's no playing involved.
I don't play dude.
I don't play games.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
that's all made in China,
right?
The Foxconn of course.
It makes all of the apple iPhone.
Yeah.
I wonder who makes the nets
outside of Foxconn measures.
They were American nets.
That'd be really ironic.
We send American nets over the Chinese
factory to catch the workers as they
jumped from the building.
Imagine that.
No,
it's weird man.
It's weird when you find out how much
shit China makes when they duplicate
cities and stuff like that.
Like they duplicate Paris and
all these other European cities.
Yeah.
One of the funniest,
funniest,
one of the most necessary towns that
they just got finished doing was a
geriatric old age town for
200,000 elderly Chinese.
Well,
you think 200,000 elderly when
there's 1.3 plus billion people there.
So the town has everything.
It's got,
you know,
stores.
We can buy diapers,
you can buy,
you know,
liquid,
uh,
drinks and protein hospitals,
their own er,
everything just for I think at 60 years
of age and older and they're building
town after town just to
take care of the elderly.
They have a really weird thing
going on with their children too.
Obviously the one child now,
it's now unlimited or it's too,
it's no longer one,
not they.
It's actually just a slight variation.
The slight variation is if you came
from a single parent household,
if you an only child,
rather,
if you were an only child,
one of your,
uh,
either the male or the
female was an only child,
you were allowed to
have more than one kid,
then you can have too.
Let's not much of a change.
It's not like unlimited,
that's still like they're
really trying to restrict,
but they have too many people.
I mean they,
they know it.
Everybody knows it and it's craziness.
And so their solution
was to only have men,
which is a crazy fucking solution.
I mean,
then you have like this crazy set up where
70 plus percent of the people are men
and the men are lonely and sad and
they can't find a woman and they,
they have this real despair because they
might not ever be able to find a woman.
It's real possibility.
There's just not that many.
That's right.
And the chicks must just be on.
That shit was so powerful there in China.
They must be so powerful,
so hard to get one,
but it's their culture has an
OLED allowed them to be that way.
Keeping Dally,
that's easy for you to say white man.
You gotta keep him.
Got to keep them in their place.
There's only,
you know,
it was only 30 of them.
You can't let them know
how the valuable they are
to many people,
man,
whether it's China or India,
what you get to a billion.
I wonder how long it's going to
take for us to get to a billion
with the immigration
that's happening fast.
You think so?
I think so.
All through Mexico?
Is that what you're saying?
Nope,
there's
most senior I heard most newer.
Oh,
there's a what,
21 million coming from China.
21 million hundred 1 million a year.
21 million that between now and 2020
there'll be 21 million people and they
predict there'll be someplace between
six to 10 million coming just to
California
if you will.
They all get in.
Don't do it.
Is there like a number
that the United States,
if they won't come anymore,
if they bring a company here,
they can get a green
with say 2,105 years ago.
Oh,
expert u s population to hit 1
billion by 2100 fucking crazy man.
Not too far off.
That's not too far off.
That means that conceivably Jamie
could still be alive to see this.
You and I will be gone unless
some new shit comes along.
But Jamie and I see this coming on.
Yeah,
there is always new shit coming along,
right?
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Jeez.
Yeah.
That's a billion is a scary number
because it represents chaos,
not just chaos,
but also represents,
there's,
there seems to be like a lack of
appreciation for life when it gets to that
level.
And that's when you find like these
crazy rapes in India and this horrible
stories of people doing terrible things.
China,
people selling their kids like people.
Not to say that people don't
do terrible things over here.
They definitely do.
People do terrible things everywhere,
but it seems like life is not as
valuable when there's too much of it
true
there.
You know,
the,
uh,
China and the black market for organs,
Middle East for Oregon's and children.
I mean,
these aren't my favorite
topics to go through.
I read about it because I am across
an international marketplace and it's
extremely scary,
you know,
with three daughters and having to
look at that one can be pulled off the
street,
you know,
and sold as and is,
um,
uh,
in slavery,
which is very,
very common.
You see all the cases that have been
coming up with Middle East and with China.
And how about with Ohio?
No,
it wasn't that fucking guy.
What did he live in?
Ohio.
Cleveland.
Yeah.
The Cleveland Guy.
When they found he had a bunch
of women living in his basement.
He had kidnapped him and
locked him up in his basement.
There's a,
this is where there's been a few
of those over the past few years.
So it's not just there,
you know,
it's not just China.
A woman has to be worried
about that here too.
All over the world.
Yeah.
It's all over.
I am just talking about,
you know,
the venues that I traveling
and hear the stuff going on.
That thing that happened in India.
Fuck,
you know?
Yeah.
There's so much rape and sane Pakistan,
these stories.
And the other thing is also
the perspective because
I mean without a doubt,
any of those stories
about gang rape in India,
they're horrible and
disgusting and terrifying.
I think the reason why we're hearing
about so many crimes from there though is
that we can't even realize what
it's like to have an extra,
like what we have now,
plus an extra 700 million,
like that's out of control.
And you know that that might
be the problem in itself.
This insane psycho behavior might be
that there's so many people that when it
gets to that level,
that life just gets devalued.
Well,
fortunately in China they have
lots of places to spread out to,
so,
but they're all concentrated,
you know,
in areas like Beijing and Shanghai and
Guang Chao and Kenton and so forth.
What?
It's it's wall to wall.
That's insane.
Like Japan.
Yeah.
Sardines in a can in the trains.
They push people in there.
That really puts you in.
That's so fucking crazy.
When we look at California
with the expansive horizons
that we have in Texas and
Alaska,
I mean,
we're very blessed to have
these beautiful places that,
you know,
my fear that we have so many people
coming in that it starts crowding us in.
The cities were already
having the crowding,
Chicago,
New York,
Los Angeles,
San Francisco,
San Diego,
so you have to look for Bumfuck,
Iowa or core de Lane.
Beautiful places.
Yeah.
They might be the last bastions of hope,
you know it.
It really seems like if people keep
expanding the population at this rate,
it's almost inevitable that the whole
country gets dragged into the same
situation that we've seen and
these other countries just,
it's almost inevitable numbers wise,
right?
You're just going to run
into an uncontrollable
unmanageable size of humans,
whether it's 500 million or a
billion or whatever the number is.
Yeah.
And he says,
just really ACL,
Lou will get in there and say,
what are you trying to restrict to one
child per family than I ever do that?
Yeah.
Well,
I hope so,
but still,
somebody's got to do something.
It's just the question of,
you know,
you don't want to really let nature take
its course because what nature we'll
deal say,
oh,
there's too many.
You fuckers,
let's just give you a horrible disease.
You know,
what's,
just give you some ruthless shit that
you'll never recover from and killed 99%
of you.
And that's what nature would do.
Nature would just figure
out a way to fuck you.
So if we don't,
if we don't fix it ourselves,
nature fixes it.
You hope.
Yeah.
And you hope we don't accelerate it
with all our genetic engineering.
Are you worried about that?
I'm extremely worried about it.
Um,
since uh,
you know,
GMO has been around,
we've been seeing an
increase in CELIAC's disease.
We'd been seeing autoimmune
diseases like Lupus or articles.
Now starting to confirm what we thought
that there is an association with gluten
from breads from grains and a lupus and
rheumatoid arthritis and Hashimoto's,
which are all names for diseases that
create inflammation and start destroying
our own selves,
our own tissue,
our bones,
rheumatoid arthritis.
And there are articles now coming out
showing that there's this relationship to
it.
And then you look back of when GMO started
with Monsanto and some of the other
companies and you start seeing the trend,
the increase in these diseases.
Why didn't we have these
diseases in the past like autism?
Why is autism at such an incredible level?
What is it,
one to 21 to 50,
when it used to be one to
400 is it relative to the
immunizations we went from,
you know,
a small amount of immunizations now giving
but 30 in a year to the kids between,
you know,
up to five years.
I don't remember really
what the numbers are.
I stopped pediatrics years ago.
But when you inject all
these inflammatory chemicals,
I mean that's what happens when
you and do an immunization.
It creates inflammation.
This is a hot topic and it's,
it's a very,
like when you start talking about it,
like there's people that are
immediately going to dismiss you.
Yep.
So you started talking about it always
one of those anti immunization guys.
But if you realize the statistics,
if you start looking at
the statistics for the,
uh,
the vaccine,
would vaccine court decide the payout?
They've,
they've had a payout,
numerous large settlements with people,
millions and millions and millions
of dollars because they connected the
immunization shots to
their kids getting autism.
Correct.
That's a weird thing.
People don't want to hear that fact.
No,
I mean they could say,
well,
they just lost in court because
it was a misinformed judge or,
I mean there can be some variables,
but the reality of the situation is
you're not supposed to give a baby peanut
butter.
Okay.
A fucking little tiny baby shouldn't
even get peanut butter because it could
kill him.
If that kid is allergic to peanuts,
if she's got that allergy,
you could literally kill
a baby with peanut butter,
but why is it okay to just shoot chemicals
in and assume that everyone's going
to have a uniform reaction
to these chemicals?
Are Most people going to be okay?
Yes.
Is it good that we have vaccinations
because they print it prevents from
diseases abso-fucking-lutely I've had
a bunch of vaccinations in my life.
I think they're very important.
Should you give them the babies?
I don't fucking know about that.
I don't know about that.
I don't know.
Maybe we should look at that
real quick because what?
What are you shooting in that?
It's,
it's,
you know,
it's a baby.
It's a day old.
You're going to shoot chemicals that
maybe let it sit around for a while and
grow and get stronger maybe.
And that's what a lot of doctors think.
They think that this should be a protocol.
We don't give them any shots
until they get to be about two.
And then you slowly start
introducing him to the essentials.
You avoid.
Like when they're babies,
you don't give him things to prevent VD,
you know?
But people want to do that kind of shit.
Like there's a lot of money and met
fucking vaccines and as soon as a
corporation gets behind the bottom line,
they're just trying to sell more.
They'll try to figure out
a way to make it so like,
look,
the fucking kid can take it.
These kids are strong these days.
They're eating our GMO corn.
You can give him a hard vaccine,
man.
We'd be making a lot of money.
Tommy,
come on.
Well,
one of the recent ones for adult females
or adolescent females is a product for
HPV,
human papillomavirus,
which can cause cervical cancer protocol,
Garnett cell.
And there are reported cases of healthy
women who get the garden of cell and end
up with problems with their brain.
Oh.
And the issue is,
you know,
from the young and also for any age really
is the protection that our body has.
This,
this wall,
this barrier called the blood brain
barrier that stops things that are caustic
and harmful to our brain from getting in.
It doesn't fully develop to maybe five
years of age in the average child.
So when you're giving an overwhelming
amount of inflammatory injections,
it creates an immune response
and it goes into the brain.
Well,
it passes that him,
that inflammatory process into
the brain and that's probably,
and they'll deny it.
You know,
the part of the reason why it happens,
they were talking about,
uh,
Theo,
which is mercury that used to be in or
is still in some of the immunizations.
They thought it was mercury toxicity.
And you know,
my partner in,
um,
in
this is all scientific facts.
It's all scientific.
Yes.
And that,
that alone,
there's the people that are
automatically dismissing you right now.
And I'm sure there were a bunch.
And me as well,
and they should dismiss me because I'm a
fucking idiot and I don't know what I'm
talking about.
I'm just repeating a bunch of
words that I've read online.
Dismiss me away please.
But,
but recognize that this is not
as cut and dry as you think.
And it's not that immunizations are bad.
It's not.
Everybody wants to say,
oh,
he's anti someone's anti-vaccine.
Oh she's,
she's causing the deaths of thousands
because she doesn't endorse giving babies
vaccines.
No,
that's not the case.
But what the case is is you got to
realize it's a fucking chemical.
And the idea that just shooting a foreign
chemical into a baby is totally safe.
Like you sure are.
You fucking sure how her,
the little baby body is going to react
to a needle being shoved into it and you
inject some manmade chemicals that
just might have mercury in them.
Everybody's going to be okay.
Well,
I agree with you that we
all need immunizations.
I think it's the timing
that we need to reassess.
I think if you're overwhelmed,
nothing,
you're correct,
sir.
I've done the story correct.
You've done your reading.
Well,
I've done a lot of reading
about the people much smarter
than me figuring things
out.
And one of the things they figured
out is a babies are fucking genuinely
sensitive.
Correct.
They're really small and they,
this is the not really developed yet.
It doesn't mean that
like vaccines are bad.
Vaccines are awesome vaccines.
And the reason why we
don't have polio vaccines,
the reason why there's a
million things like mumps,
which is actually starting
to make a comeback because
people are not vaccinating
their kids from mumps and measles,
you know?
So it's not entirely good
to not vaccinate either.
It's,
it's,
it's good.
It's just,
it needs to be done at
the right time probably.
And we need to figure out
why there's so many of them.
I mean,
are they all necessary?
Are we sure that that's a good idea?
And I don't think there's any way to
do it until they clone fake people,
headless people,
and they use it or using it as prisoners.
Prisoners,
that's what they should do.
Give them vaccines.
You can't do that because you've got to
test them on babies and you need to make
fake babies.
That's the only way to do it.
You don't have to make it.
But then there'll be,
you know,
a lot of people that are
convinced that they're,
they've made a real baby.
Cause it'd be,
you'd have to be so perfect in
order for my experiments to work,
write it up as a thesis.
It's a good TV show.
It's like a one of those a CSI shows,
but it's all about fake babies.
Yeah,
man.
Um,
I think that a lot of people
want an either or in that case,
and I'm glad that you have the courage to,
uh,
to talk about that because you know,
as well as I know that it's such a hot
topic that immediately even discussing
the possibility that occasionally there
could be problems when you inject kids,
people,
people assume you're like a nine,
11 truther,
you know,
you believe the towers were
broken down by thermite.
Like they put you in that
nutter category right away.
You're a chem trail believer.
You're a fucking UFO fanatic.
You know where big foot lives,
boom,
I've got his address.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah,
absolutely.
You know,
they think that,
I mean you made a comment about it.
We're all the same,
we're not all the same and you give the
same products to 90 different people and
you get 90 different reactions.
You hope you get a couple of
them that have no reaction.
But they think that it's,
we live in a perfect world
and that's the problem.
They don't take into consideration that
the genetic uniqueness of each person
unquestionable genetic uniqueness.
But that's not convenient if
you just try to turn a profit.
Correct.
And that's why it's weird that
we just allow that to happen.
I mean it's not anti-science,
it's not anti-medicine it's common sense.
It's very simple.
A Co who's waiting,
hold on.
Is it profit going on here?
Well you guys are
providing how much money?
Holy Shit.
You find out how much money
is in vaccinations that much.
First of all,
why is it costs that much?
Why are you making that much money?
And second of all is that have anything
to do with why they give so many
vaccinations?
Is that possible?
And if you think it could be,
if you think that people are sneaky and
slimy enough that there that could be,
it has to be something that we
all take into consideration.
It doesn't mean that you're a nutter.
It means like that's like that seems like
a writing on the wall kind of a thing.
It's all about profit.
I'll give you an example that you might've
heard less weak company came out with
a new drug for hepatitis C.
Hepatitis C is a chronic process.
That viral infection,
we don't really have very
good treatment for it.
They use Gamma Alpha Interferon.
It doesn't work that well.
They came out with a drug,
one capsule a day for 84 days.
It's cost $1,000 a tablet.
It costs them $2 billion to get
it to where it is right now.
There are 4.1 million people in
the United States with hepatitis C.
It'll only take 250,000
to pay off everything.
And they've got 4.1 million
people with Hepatitis C.
So the argument is why doesn't
the company lower the cost for it?
So it would make it more available
to more people discussed.
They have,
you know,
a program for hardship cases and the
CEO was on this radio program that I was
listening to and he says,
it's not our model to lower the price.
Whoa,
it's not our model.
It's their model.
We want $1,000 a pill,
dollars a pill.
Is it because the research and
development costs were so high?
Well,
they're saying it was very high and
they bought the technology from another
company,
but it's a,
you know,
you do 250,000 times 84,000 and that's
the amount of money that it costs them to
do everything that they've done.
It just seems like if you give people
the opportunity to make more or less
money,
it's up to them.
Well this is what it is.
Some people that go fucking
crazy and it's like gasoline.
Why is gasoline 47 cents in Abu Dhabi?
Right.
But you know,
but you can't like limited either.
That's what's weird about being a person.
Me,
he can't tell people
what to do either way.
You know,
he can't.
It's,
it's hard to tell them what to do.
I mean,
it's hard to say what year?
Well,
how can I say that?
You know,
you are your shit cost too much.
Your pills cost too much.
When,
uh,
maybe I'm not willing
to work for less either.
And everybody goes,
ah,
we'll just leave it alone.
Well,
the economy of scale is if you're making
$7 and 50 cents an hour working 40
hours a week,
how can you afford to pay $1,000 a pill?
It's craziness.
It's so much money.
It's an insane amount of money.
But if it has research and
development funded when they,
when they do something like that,
how long does stuff like that tank?
Like if they're going to develop
some sort of a crazy pill,
what's like a high end figure?
High end could be,
you know,
10,
15 years on the short,
which is a fast track that
they have with the FDA.
It's three years.
And the only problem with that,
if you look the past five,
10 years,
the drugs that went
through the fast track,
there were a number of them that were
taken off the market because of the side
effects that they didn't see
in the first three years.
Well,
they were there.
There was one drug that was for a form
of leukemia that was just taken off the
market where it caused your blood
vessels in your limbs to shut down.
So your leg would lose ischemias
the term lose bloods hallway.
So it would go dead and they'd
have to amputate your live a fuck.
And this is what was going on.
There was another drug that
was for ovarian cancer,
which is a very drastic thing.
Um,
Jean Wilde's,
a wife,
uh,
from laughing,
died of ovarian cancer anyway.
Um,
and they had it out for a year.
At the end of the year,
the FDA took it off the market because
they found that it had no status to
statistical benefit.
Nope.
People think that better.
Wow.
So how was it that they were
allowed to have this drug marketed?
I don't know how many thousand
dollars it was per treatment,
but it was just phenomenal.
And the drug for Hipaa,
for a diabetes,
which,
um,
was taken off the market after
a year because of liver failure.
Then the,
you know,
the,
um,
uh,
anti inflammatory medication,
Vioxx with a cardiac problem.
I was just going to bring that up.
I know a dude who had a
stroke because of that stuff.
He had a,
he guy Metzger is his name.
He's a former UFC fighter,
like a really elite fighter and one of
the pioneers of MMA and a handsome guy to
fucking beautiful head of hair.
He's a,
he does a commentary now and he was
apparently taking it because he had
arthritis in his knees.
He has it real bad.
Inflammation is knees.
And then his,
uh,
his family,
people around them start saying like,
what's going on man?
You're like slurring your words,
like what's happening?
Stroke.
He realized he had had a stroke and
then it turns out that a bunch of people
that took this stuff and had strokes,
he's made a full recovery.
But you know,
it's because he's a young,
healthy guy.
But that's fucking scary shit.
Yeah.
So basically not everybody has
a side effect of medications.
Medications generally are very good.
You just have to be cautious
when you start into those little
five pound six pound critters.
We called kids babies.
Well,
yeah,
I mean,
and even fucking MMA fighters,
205 pound Guy Metzger's I mean,
it's pretty much everybody's
gotta be careful.
It's a,
it's a,
it's not,
it's not totally figured out yet.
You know,
not with every single human being.
There's a lot of variables that people
have to work with when they make drugs or
solutions.
You just,
the,
the variables or the different amount
of places where people came from.
Of course there's different things that
they were exposed to in their ancestors.
Jeans,
you know?
Yeah.
If you ever had genetic testing,
no,
no.
I'm a chimp.
I don't think I qualified
for being a person.
It definitely would have about three
and a half of neanderthal might be a
missing link.
They know they'll find neanderthal.
Yeah.
I know.
Someone in my family fucked a monkey.
Someone down the line,
someone down the line
totally fucked a monkey.
I don't want to find out that I'm more
neanderthal than a regular person.
But then they say the Niana
tiles looking up lately,
by the way,
I've been reading.
Yeah,
no,
no.
They started to think that may have been
a little smarter than when people are
giving him credit for it.
Might even be able to talk,
might've been able to,
uh,
they use tools.
They know that,
uh,
they,
they think that neanderthals were
very similar to human beings,
but just,
uh,
not quite,
you know,
I took the alien genetics
to bring him up to homo hug.
I don't know.
At kiss and Homosapien and homo erectus.
That's what I was just going to tell you
it for me.
You've got the process.
Yeah.
No,
they still haven't figured out how
neanderthal jumped all the way up to homo
erectus.
Homo bilocation homosapien and the
diff distinction was the front,
the cortex or the NEOCORTEX,
the new brain part,
which is how we get our language skills
when we get our thought processes and
integration of our emotion and you know,
and uh,
control frontal lobes with a command
and executive functions and uh,
you know,
they still looking for that missing link.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's a fascinating thing,
the whole process of trying to figure
out our past with fossils because fossils
are really difficult to create.
You,
you know,
you have to get caught in some sort of
a natural disaster or a mudslide or you
know,
something's going to happen
to preserve the body.
Cause normally buys will
get eaten by scavengers.
I mean,
that's what scavengers are there for.
And especially in those days,
man,
you know,
I'm sure there was a lot of death.
Things were just dying.
People weren't living as long.
So the idea that,
you know,
we can,
we can figure out our entire fossil
record just by finding bones,
but boy,
that's a fucking shitty
record we're dealing with.
They just found,
I think a partial skull,
which is the oldest,
a hundred thousand years old
or a hundred million years old.
I don't remember what the,
how many Zeros are after it,
but,
uh,
you know,
there was finding a new ancestor.
Yes.
Do you see that article?
I've seen several of them.
There's
been,
there's been a lot of new
discoveries over the past,
like about,
say 10 or so years ago whenever it
was that they discovered that Hobbit,
man Flores,
do you know about that?
No.
Homo Floresiensis I believe is
the term that the hobbit people,
they were three foot tall,
little like chimp,
like people buy pedal little elves.
I mean,
they lived on a fucking island and they
think that they might've even prayed on
human children.
They think that they might've been,
that,
that could be total horse shit.
I don't know why that was even theorize,
but they thought that maybe that might
have been one of the reasons why they
killed them off that the human beings,
yeah.
That there was some preparation
between the two species.
That's it.
Just a theory.
Um,
and it's not mine by the way,
but they think that that,
that has occurred in some places were
chimps have got in and stolen babies and
they eat the babies.
But that's just,
yeah,
but in your little people.
Yeah.
But what they're saying is that primates,
yes.
We'll sort of people like,
I mean they were very,
very,
very primitive,
but they lived as recently as 10,000,
15,000 years ago.
So if 10,000,
50,000 years ago,
humans weren't in this exact form.
And we were dealing with these
weird little chimp people like this,
look at these things.
Like they have the,
uh,
the,
the various forms of humans,
that little tiny thing.
That's it.
That's the homofloresiensis Jamie,
see if you could pull up
a better picture of it.
Cause there's some interesting
drawings that they did,
like individual ones,
like one of the ones you showed earlier.
Well,
there's homo erectus look like to do with
a big Dick or wrecked homo erectus at
two and he's gay.
Bad.
Yeah.
It's terrible joke.
This,
um,
but this hobbit person thing,
right?
I mean this absolutely without
doubt walked alongside with people.
So if you see that person there and PR,
well that guy's yoked.
Who is that guy?
The cokes like Gleason t
bow looking at he's stacked,
but that's a rare person.
Don't compare that size.
But the um,
the little hobbit guy right next to him,
it's really fascinating stuff man.
Does that means that all those stories
that the Indonesian people would tell,
uh,
and there's a,
there's a,
a like a la,
the Orang Pendek that um,
there's a jungle people
say is still alive.
They still think there's a small
population of these things.
It's still exist and they
call it the Orang Pendek.
So little a chimp,
like a tiny person that
lives in the forest.
Fucking crazy man.
If those,
if there is a small amount of those people
that are still actually actually left
living in some crazy rain forest
somewhere that's not outside the realm of
possibility,
much more likely than bigfoot,
that there's this little hobbit,
man that's still alive because
that was always the legend.
And when they found this
in the island of Flores,
they're like,
Holy Shit.
Like three Flores.
Um,
that's a good question.
It's near Florida.
No,
it's near Flores.
Uh,
yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know where it is.
I think it's like Sumatra
or something like that.
Maybe I just made that up.
Isn't that like a,
what part of the world is it?
Probably all vitamin D deficient.
All those people to be so short.
Okay.
In Indonesia,
Indonesia,
well,
there's a term called um,
uh,
island dwarfism and it
applies to primates.
Sometimes it plays to elephants.
You get like these tiny pygmy
elephants and that are on islands,
but not to lizards.
Lizards get bigger.
If you leave lizards on an island,
they actually grow.
That's why you have like the Komodo
dragons and like big fucking crazy lizards
like crocodiles and shit.
They actually grow when
they're on islands.
Yeah.
The reason,
because they have
everything can't get away,
so they just eat everything.
He's his gang up on bitches.
Just take them out.
You know,
if you're on an island with
a family of Komodo dragons,
good luck.
One day they're going to
find out they can eat you.
You know they're going to sneak up on
you and find out that they can eat you.
And if you can't go anywhere
because you're on an island,
the lizards are always going to win.
Strange and that,
yeah.
Would you looking at,
Oh,
the Komodo Dragon.
what about it?
I was expecting a picture up there.
He's looking for,
you never see the commercial.
It was on a double o seven
had one where you really,
do you have a pet?
Yeah.
So it was in the movie,
which is the last one.
The last one where the radio is.
What is his name?
Daniel.
Craig.
Daniel Craig.
Yeah.
Where would they,
they were in Hong Kong or a at a casino?
Yeah.
They accident evil.
Fucking lizard.
So could you imagine you hear
that walking outside of your tent,
your wash up on the beach,
like don't worry,
honey.
We have a tent.
Look at that fucking creepy thing.
Probably hasn't changed in forever.
Neat.
Remorseless Monster.
It's fascinating to think that
that was the entire earth,
isn't it?
Yeah.
I mean that's essentially a dinosaur,
right?
Right.
It's about as close to the dinosaurs.
You can get them in crocodiles.
How much different is there
from a crocodile to a dinosaur?
It seems pretty,
pretty similar.
I want one of those.
You want to crocodile?
Not when a Komodo Dragon,
what would you do with it?
Would you stand up there and
your underwear and take pictures?
What'd you do?
Oh,
I'm afraid to get bitten.
No,
what a great watchdog.
Not really.
It's going to eat.
You watch good watchdogs like their owner.
That thing doesn't give a shit about you.
You want a good watch dog?
I'll give it away to someone I don't like.
Yeah,
get,
get out.
You know,
get a bird.
Get something that squawks
when people are outside,
get a flamingo or something.
I've got two cats and two dogs.
That's enough.
He cocks I guess make noises.
Hunter s Thompson used to have
him in his place and Woody Creek.
When people come near the peacocks to go,
let me crazy noises and I'll let
you know that people are coming.
The good guards or at least alert.
It's got alarms.
Military Macola too.
Yeah.
So,
um,
so what,
what other stuff do you think besides
this glue to on what other stuff do you
think that people should be taken
on a regular basis that they're not?
That's an incredible question.
There are a lot of things that we're
losing in our water for say for instance,
uh,
we get bottled water.
What's in it?
Nothing filtered water,
filtered water,
no minerals were the minerals,
the minerals.
We're probably all to some degree mineral
deficient in one of the ones that the
federal government talked about
back in the late nineties,
uh,
was c Everett Koop talked about
it in fact was a chromium.
Chromium is an anti
diabetic because it helps,
uh,
insulin work better in your body.
It's called the glucose tolerance factor.
Chromium.
And we found that,
uh,
because of our farming technology
that we haven't been burning the,
the leftover crop to get the
ash potash back into the soil,
that we're losing a lot of the minerals.
Uh,
we,
everything we get is filtered.
So we lose all the trace magnesium,
molybdenum,
all the trace elements that we need for
very important chemical pathways in our
body.
So we're running around with
a deficiency of function.
And the only way to improve upon that
function is to replenish minerals.
And you can get trace minerals.
I mean,
it doesn't really matter where you
get as long as it's a high quality
bioavailable kind of product.
There are a lot of vitamins that are
a lot of minerals that you can absorb
because they're cheap.
Sulfated ones.
Getting the citrate is a lot better.
The glucarate and the fumarate or much
better forms of whether or not it's a
zinc or magnesium or so forth.
Do you think people should
take them in a colloidal farm?
Like how has that Hook colloidal minerals?
Neurosis is a suspended one,
so it gets absorbed a lot better.
Instead of taking it in
a compressed tablets,
I don't use anything that's compressed.
I use only a powdered encapsuled powder,
uh,
with a vegetable out of code on it.
When that,
um,
so like when you,
when you take colloidal minerals,
they collect them from some mineral rich
streams or something like that or the
ad.
How do they,
if they're,
if they're artificial,
you know,
they're making it too.
They're suspending it so
that it's easy absorbed.
There is a cistern in,
um,
New Zealand where,
it's about a 50 million year old sister
and which has a blend from erosion from
the walls of the sister and uh,
with natural water,
clean,
fresh water and it has a balance in it,
which gives you a water a Ph of eight.
And uh,
you know,
I don't want to really get into the
thing about acid based kind of chemistry.
What does that mean by a Ph?
A Ph eight is,
uh,
more Aukland,
which is called Aukland warrant.
And the benefits of alkaline
water versus acidic water acidic.
Um,
you know,
we have ionizers that take a regular
tap water and make it into smaller
molecules.
What is an interesting molecule?
Because it doesn't stay singular.
It's just not one h,
two o water molecule.
It clumps together in a lot of water
molecules stick together because of the
electrical attraction of it,
of the Ma,
each molecule to the next
it would ionize water is no ionize water,
puts a charge in it to separated.
So it's more absorbable.
I mean,
I've had patients come into the officer's,
Hey doc,
I'm drinking,
you know,
my eight ounces every two
hours and I'm still thirsty.
And it's because they're
drinking acidic water,
which clumps together and doesn't
allow for bio available water.
And you'll start seeing
some stuff that says,
you know,
bio available water and you know,
it's going gonna take some time for our
brain to accept it are our position,
uh,
to accept these new trends
because they say it's,
you know,
it's bullshit.
You don't need Aukland.
And yet there's no
thing with acid outcome.
There are articles that,
you know,
refute the benefits of it,
but I see it in clinical application
with patients who have failed certain
medication and they go onto an
alkalizing protocol and they get better.
And I documented they shouldn't be better,
but they're better.
They're symptomatic complaints of
pain and swelling and all that's gone.
Why do you say shouldn't?
Why it shouldn't be costs?
In my medical training,
I don't see,
you know,
in my training,
I've been in practice 32 years and had
13 and a half years of a training with a
year and a half of research
and it shouldn't happen,
but it is happening.
So when you go back and you
look at the fringe science,
you start realizing that on the fringe
it hasn't come full cycle into the core
of,
of our belief system that uh,
the products have,
um,
uh,
means what Aukland water has a means by
which it changes the acid base of our
body and our body does much
better in Aukland situations.
Inflammation.
If your body is acidic,
more inflammatory diseases occur,
but you can't prove it.
It's supposition.
It's,
you know,
speculation.
We don't have enough hard documentation
to prove it and there's a lot of
resistance to develop that hard scientific
information right near right now.
And with everything that's on the fringe,
everything that's new that comes into
medicine does a lot of resistance are
cycled in medicine is about
30 years because you've got
30 years doctors who are
in practice for 30 years
who control everything.
And that's old school stuff that I used
to work on was 20 years old doctors
nowadays.
I mean I interact with training doctors
and the information that they're running
their practices on so antiquated,
you know,
it's like doctor still think that
testosterone causes prostate cancer and
there's not a single shred
of evidence that proves it.
One of our docs from Harvard,
doctor Abraham Morgan Fellow wrote the
book to start from for life where he
spends his,
you know,
academic,
uh,
life at Harvard and in Boston proving
that there's nothing to substantiate that
testosterone causes cancer.
What does cause test testicular cancer?
Cause that's a really common one with men,
uh,
to stickler as seminomas
to stick your cancer.
Um,
you know,
there's
genetic predisposition for it and
there's also thermal temperature.
There's an increased occurrence
in men who have had what they call
cryptorchidism crypto is hidden testicle
where they haven't had descended
testicles.
So if their pediatrician was on
time and gave them a shot of Hcg,
which causes the testicle to drop,
then it drops out of the
98 degree temperature that
the testicle isn't made to
function it.
That's why it hangs out in artistic,
in our sick,
in our ball sack.
Okay.
Stupid design.
Well,
but there's a reason for it.
They want it to be degrees,
uh,
less so.
It doesn't induce cancer.
Our sperm are germ cells and germ cells
have a chemical germ cells like cancer
and germ cells have a
high reproductive rate.
What happens when you get fixed?
When a dude gets fixed?
Oh,
you mean for this cord?
when it cuts cords.
Yeah.
What is it called?
What's it called?
Vasectomy.
Yeah.
I'm an east coast.
You're familiar to say by vasectomy.
Oh,
I thought it was,
it's a v the snip,
snip,
snip.
Come up with a word.
Right.
For the sector.
Is there any half sick to me?
Is that bad for people?
Um,
no,
it's not bad.
It's,
you know,
stops having kids that you
shouldn't have for subs,
having kids that you would like
to have that you can't afford.
Right.
But is there any,
absolutely.
But is there any medical,
no concerns that someone would have?
No.
Um,
the,
the uncomfortable nature of the procedures
psychologically I think is worse than
the physical aspect to it.
So do you think dudes lose,
like when,
when they,
they're shooting blanks,
they lose like the psychological
feeling of actually being potent,
um,
because they have just dead calm.
There's calpers pellets and they have
the prostate which generate fluids.
It's not just the,
the swimmers,
you know,
there's definitely something
missing to the batch though.
There's a volume is decreased,
but there were ways of increasing volume.
There's volume that's decreased
and you don't have as intense of a,
um,
orgasms,
orgasms or ropes.
So they're not as good.
Orgasms are not as good.
And in the majority of people,
there's no effect on it.
The majority of people know what if
you're one of those people and you already
got snipped and it's
right and you're like,
oh,
fuck me.
What if coming goes from
the greatest thing ever?
Tell him,
all right,
whatever.
Then you have to sit on the
couch and talk about it.
Then he got to reattach this,
the plumbing,
I can do that,
right?
They go in there and micro
surgically reattach your,
uh,
correct packer pump.
They could do that or us that go
in and they just suck out the,
uh,
the sperm from your testicle,
the needle.
Oh,
hey,
that's,
that doesn't seem like anybody
should have to do that option.
So that's the option.
They do it every now and again.
Oh Man.
How long would they have to do that for?
Like,
that's a male,
like a mail shot.
If,
no,
if a male has a low sperm count and
he wants to get his wife knocked up,
uh,
they'll try with growth hormone,
testosterone,
zinc,
and other ways of trying to stimulate
increase in the sperm count.
But if they're not producing sperm,
uh,
for whatever reason,
they can take a needle,
put it in and aspirate to suck outs.
That's sounds crazy.
Aspirate is a better word.
It means suck out.
Yeah.
I would have asked you what to ask,
right?
So yes.
Aspiration.
This,
the idea of it,
like if you said the ETA
stick a needle in my Gsi,
I'd be like,
all right.
You know the deal and
my shoulder over there.
All right,
but you're talking about pulling
something out of my penis.
I'm really not comfortable with that.
But out of your testicle.
Yeah,
man.
It doesn't seem like a good idea.
That seems like it's got
to be a way around that,
but that's how we fix him.
Fertility when it's not the woman's fault.
Jesus though a fucking needle
and your Dick Together.
It happens.
Yeah.
The adult industry,
they use Caverject.
They inject in the bass.
I love how you say the adult
industry or what should I say?
Porn.
That's what it is.
The industry.
What about the child industry?
Is it different?
You have a different industry.
You can't use the term adult if you
can't use the term child in the same
business.
Okay.
Now like what is the industry
that these is that all adults are,
they just want to fuck.
Like that's the adult.
The real adult is just
like living your life.
It's a bunch of bullshit,
but this is what you really want to do.
You really just want to fuck.
So that's why we call
it the adult industry.
That's a terrible message for the children
that your life is based in Thailand,
sexually sexual pressure as you get older.
What do you come to the two
most important things in life?
Um,
food and sleep.
Okay.
Sexual pleasure.
Of course.
I'm just joking.
Just joking.
I know you're,
but it's just funny
that you used that word.
Adults,
adult people use that.
It's like urban for black people,
you know,
it's like they don't
want to say black people,
but they can say urban and it means
exact same thing and somehow or another
people just let it slide.
So what should I use instead
of the adult industry?
Uh,
the porn porn or far,
it's nothing wrong with porn industry.
They use a chemical,
which in fact comes from a,
a woman,
uh,
PGE,
which Prostoglandin e and they inject
it in the base of the penis and it makes
them have a erection that lasts
for like two to four hours,
like a baseball bat.
That's such a strange thing.
They take something out of the woman,
they inject into the man
and the man gets rock hard.
Do you think that that is like they're
in a woman to make a man or wrecked like
she has the ability to do that chemical
in the man in his sperm when he had
Jackie plates in a woman who is pregnant,
it can cause her to deliver.
Maybe,
you know,
I'm okay.
I fuck.
So what is this stuff that a woman
has that they take out with a needle?
You don't take it out for,
but it's a,
it's a chemical in her.
Well,
how did she have it?
Where's it in her body?
It's her body.
She had to come out in a
sweat or anything like that.
Oh,
you'd like pheromones?
Yes.
Um,
I'm not sure to be perfectly must
come out of her vagina for sure.
Absolutely.
Out of the bag.
That's why we're all attracted to him.
Yeah.
It comes out of China,
not the one.
Right.
Well that's not true.
You can be attracted to both Mr. Gordon.
How dare you.
ABS.
It's not an either or situation
services free for all.
Here it is a damn Claypool.
Yeah,
but mean.
That only makes sense.
Why a eating pussy gives guys hard on,
sorry,
I had to say it that way.
Right?
Look,
it's the pheromone.
Get upset at me,
ladies and gentlemen.
What I'm going to say fellatio and you go,
who are you?
I know her.
Fellatio Felice.
Yeah,
so
absolutely.
What can I do?
You're a bad influence.
No,
no,
no.
You're a great guy.
Semi Professional.
This,
it makes sense that a woman would have
something in her body with the smell of
it actually gives the guy erection
because that absolutely works.
Look,
look at the animals.
The guy gets horny during the estrous,
which is the female cycle of an animal
and she's throwing out pheromones.
So obviously gals were throwing up
pheromones and when you meet it,
you know,
you stand in front of,
I'll tell you the man side of it later,
when you stand in front
of a group of women,
there are certain of the women that
you're more attracted to than others.
There was a study done at Ucla where
they were looking at this issue of
pheromones and I apologize,
I forget the female doctor's name who
did all this research and developed a
product which guys can buy.
Of course there was a check.
It was a chick making money on that smell.
Absolutely.
What she found was that,
um,
she took women and she introduced
them to guys that were fat,
that we're lazy,
you know,
from smoking marijuana,
right?
Yeah.
Those legacy guys,
lazy potheads.
They didn't see him,
but they had the shirts from these guys,
so they smelled the shirt to smell
the perspiration that was on it.
And what happened almost a hundred
percent of the time was they were able to
pick the guy that was healthy,
that was a physically active,
that produced this pure
pussy perspiration.
And they found that it was guys that
were healthy that didn't have any medical
conditions,
so women can sense through the pheromones.
So the pheromones transmit understanding
about the condition of the person.
They picked,
the guys that were fat,
they picked the guys that were healthy,
so she took the chemicals
or the synthesize this
stuff that they found in the
healthy guys.
And that's her Fairmont.
That's fascinating.
And injured 50 bucks I think
for a little bottle of perfume.
And I think that totally makes sense.
I mean,
if we know that pheromones exist and
you know that when you were like really
attracted to someone to the,
the intensity,
like when you're touching
them and just being near them,
they like it,
like take turns on something.
And it absolutely could be for
emotional as well as physical,
as well as pleasure based in sensitivity
than it'd be some pheromone exchanges
too.
Right.
But I think that the pheromones
really set you up for everything.
Look yet,
you know,
in,
um,
it's neuroendocrinology,
which is the way hormones
work in the brain,
which is what I spend
most of my time doing.
Um,
pheromones trigger,
um,
pleasurable centers,
centers in the brain.
You know,
we have centers in a low libido area,
which is another way saying
the sex area of the brain.
We have an area that stimulated by,
not just to stastrom but estradal in
a recent article that came out of Jama
three,
four months ago,
and in Dr Abraham Morgan Fallon was on
the news talking about it on good morning
America or something.
And men need estrogen dial in order to
have a fully functioning sexual mindset
and women need to stop stroke.
I have a question for you.
Has there ever been
anyone so fucking dumb?
They named their kid
libido has to be right.
There has to be a guy.
It's like I'm telling you this kid always
going to want to do is fuck it when
Jamie has a chance.
There must be,
there's a libido out there somewhere,
somewhere along the line.
It's gotta be,
you're looking at the
names that are out there.
Shane.
Shame,
Star light star.
Bright Jesus fucking Christ.
What a what a mad mad world.
Yeah.
Love movie.
The,
so when we were talking about,
um,
different things that you do,
one of the things that I
didn't mention is that you're,
you're uh,
one of the,
I don't want to say a pioneer,
but one of the more prominent guys when
it comes to understanding the effects of
traumatic brain injuries and working
with guys are working with boxers and
working with,
uh,
you know,
various athletes that have suffered.
I know you've worked a
lot of people that I know.
Right.
Uh,
did you get involved in all of this?
Great question.
Um,
you know,
I've been practicing a hormonal modulation
therapy since about 1995 and I myself
was,
I'm not feeling so great
between the age of 3,446.
And in fact,
I was on antidepressant and a obese
losing my hair and just not a very happy
camper.
So I went to a company in Las Vegas and
paid them a lot of money in 97 and was
diagnosed with having
three hormone deficiencies,
growth home to stoss thrown in thyroid
and just thinking it was genetic,
ended up going on to a
replenishment treatment.
And in my practice I had started shifting
over to hormone modulation that they
used to call it what they
call anti aging medicine.
I turned to coin called Interventional
endocrinology because I don't think the
term anti aging in medicine is a
proper term for the general masses.
It's a great buzzword to
get an understanding of what
you know we do in the area
of interventional endocrinology.
So treating a lot of people
with a hormone deficiency.
In 2004 I'm reading an article out of
Turkey about pugilists boxers where they
had this uncanny high occurrence of growth
hormone deficiency and that I call my
epiphany article.
I read that it all made sense.
Head trauma creates a situation
that leads to hormonal deficiency.
So I went back to my population from 1995
to 2004 and started interviewing them
again to see who had had accidents and
almost every single person had a very
clear cut motor vehicle accident.
In the first book that I wrote,
interventional endocrinology,
chapter five talks about a 17 year
old kid who came to me at 21 with um,
significant mood changes,
depression,
anxiety,
isolation.
He couldn't gain weight.
It turned out he was hormone deficient
and when he was 21 years of age,
I go back to him and find out
that he had a motorcycle accident.
Was in a coma for three days.
No.
Wow.
So I've got kids right now that
have had motor vehicle accidents,
slip and falls,
blunt head trauma,
assaults that have had a develop hormonal
deficiency and you can develop the
hormone deficiency because the head trauma
can interrupt areas of the brain that
regulate hormone production by the
pituitary called the master gland in the
brain.
There's a regulatory sensor that test
the blood every microsecond to see if
there's a balance of girl tone,
testosterone,
estrogen and all the hormones in our body.
And if there's a deficiency of it,
it sends a signal to the master gland,
the pituitary to tell it to increase
the production of whatever hormone it
perceives as being deficient or low.
On the other hand,
if it's too high,
the same area of the brain called the
hypothalamus tells the pituitary to shut
down or decrease the
production of hormones.
So if you're making not enough growth
hormone or not enough IGF one which is the
market for growth hormone,
it'll tell the brain to
produce more growth hormone.
And the same thing with testosterone.
So I started looking at this area
since 2004 and the literature was just
starting to burgeon with a lot of
documentation research that have been done
showing that people who have head
trauma have testosterone deficiency.
Number one,
growth hormone deficiency.
Number two,
thyroid.
Number three,
cortisol,
which is the adaptive kind of hormone,
the stress hormone.
And I had one,
two and three I had growth from deficiency
to stocks from deficiency in thyroid
deficiency.
And in 2007 I had been seeing
a lot of people retired,
NFL football and rugby and a lot
of sports players and boxers.
Like,
I can say James,
Tony,
um,
and,
uh,
they were documented as having hormone
deficiency and we went on to ESPN outside
the line in 2007 and showed their lab
results and they talked about how much
better they felt when they had their
hormones returned to normal levels,
replaced a physiological levels,
not bodybuilder levels,
but physiological levels,
which is like 60 milligrams a week
versus something like I hear up to 400
milligrams a week.
Yeah.
That's something that
people really need to,
um,
it's,
it's something that people need
to understand that if you look at,
look what a bodybuilder is,
that's impossible without ridiculous,
insane numbers of chemicals that you
shoot into your body literally is
impossible.
And I think people have bad taste
in their mouth or a bad idea about the
idea of testosterone because they think,
well,
if you take testosterone,
you're taking a steroid and you're
going to become a big giant monster
direction.
Like you can't become a big giant monster
person unless you're fucking dedicated
to crushing your body.
Correct.
When I started doing hormone
replacement using testosterone,
a lot of patients that
that's a antibiotic,
that's a steroid,
don't,
don't they picked you,
you like Dorian Yates to stand
out there and your front porch.
And my response to them was steroids.
What you're buying the corner from Bubba.
What I'm giving you as a
medication called testosterone.
Why is it always Bobo?
I don't know if it gets a bad rep,
but he fucks guys in prison but was
one of the first guy to fucking prison.
Well,
I've got a limited vocabulary for,
you know,
the guy selling stuff that corners,
let's call him Lou Lou Crazy Lu,
who's got the good shit look at you.
Swoll so in the beginning it was the
hormone deficiency and not feeling as I'm
able psychologically,
physiologically and physical,
um,
diabetes increased and we're now seeing
out of literature starting in 2000 that
if you're low and free testosterone and
50 year old male and above and now 50
year old female and above,
you have a higher occurrence of diabetes.
So to start thrown serves a,
an incredible function.
Also pain.
We found that testosterone
also stops inflammation.
So people have joint aches and pains.
They go away when they replace
your testosterone level,
growth hormone and cognitive function.
The real bottom line is we know that
head trauma causes hormonal deficiency.
We know that hormone deficiency
is associated with depression,
anxiety,
and all those suicides that
we're seeing in the NFL.
And in the military in 2012,
there were more,
uh,
there were 364 homeless one a day,
64,
uh,
people in the military,
you committed suicide.
They all had pst,
you know,
post traumatic stress syndrome,
which is just another form of a Tbi,
traumatic brain injury.
Yeah,
I believe at the very least,
it mirrors the amount that,
that are killed in action.
It's scary.
I mean,
that's,
that's a scary,
scary thing.
Well,
in 2012,
there were more people committed
suicide than were killed in action.
It was more documented by the dod,
but you know,
so the,
the issue is that we do
great at diagnosing traumatic
brain injury or cts or pet
scans,
all these high tech things.
But we fail at treatment.
And the reason why we've tr fail it
treatment is because we haven't put a good
composite together of laboratory
testing for traumatic brain injury.
So what we've developed over the past
10 years is this testing to allow for
someone to have their hormones checked,
to determine if there's a brain source
for the deficiency or if the gland,
like you know,
the testicles are gone.
Of course you're not
going make testosterone.
But if you have healthy young testicles,
you should have a chemical in the
brain that's directing them to produce
testosterone called leuteinizing hormone.
Well here
comes the big question.
If this is all the case,
if a traumatic brain injuries and
concussions and whatnot are causing this
decline in the function and the,
the,
the operation of glands in the
body that produce hormones,
should the people who take that stuff
be allowed to continue whatever they've
done that's made them deficient
of all these hormones.
So the argument is like,
there's a big issue of sh
I'm sure you know about it,
and mixed martial arts.
And the big issue in mixed martial arts
is testosterone replacement therapy that
a lot of these guys are
legitimately showing up where they,
they,
they test low enough.
We're doctors prescribing testosterone.
So the question is they're there,
they need this when they're
young for one of two reasons,
right?
Either there's a medical issue,
like they could have taken steroids
and the steroids could have shut their,
their balls down.
Or if it's not that,
it's,
you know,
they could have a disease that lowers
a test or if it's not that its head
trauma.
If it is head trauma and
their businesses head trauma,
should they still be
engaging in head trauma?
Great question.
The answer is obviously no.
So
if you were like,
say if they had you running the
Nevada state athletic commission,
if you were the guy that had to oversee
boxers and mixed martial arts fighters,
if they came to you lower testosterone,
you would say,
well we're going to get
you some testosterone by,
well,
no more fighting.
Well you have to go and do some
assessment to see what the damage is.
You know,
we have some technology
that is phenomenal.
I mean if you look up on the Internet,
uh,
Dti Mri where you can actually see the
interruptions of nerve conduction in the
brain of the nerve fibers.
You can see the interruption of
the axons is what it's called.
You can also see scarring.
I had a DTI Mri done.
Uh,
it's called track two gram
or diffusion attention.
That's it.
All my God,
that's unbelievable technology.
I had this done.
My God,
that's real.
That's real.
Holy Shit.
That image looks like a
crazy flower from avatar.
Yeah.
Yes.
So what is this called again?
What is the technology d t Mri with DTI
diffusion tensor imaging and it follows
the flow of water through
the neurons new desktop.
Okay.
That's my new desk.
Send you something that is incredible.
That image is fantastic.
I don't even want to see what my
stupid fucking brand looks like.
So anyway,
you have a DTI done and you can actually
see calcifications are scars based upon
the amount of damage to the brain.
You make a decision whether or not the
person is at great risk for continuing.
And what he's doing.
Wow.
There was a university of Saint Louis,
I think just got another
$8 million grant to do DTI,
Fmri and one of the study of the brain,
which are very definitive for showing
a deficiency of blood flow from head
trauma.
You can have areas of the
brain lose their blood supply.
You can have nerve damage.
I've got some great pictures I'll send
you where you can actually see the
severing of the nerves that
connect the front to the,
you know,
the frontal lobe to the cortex.
So you lose,
uh,
decision making.
The ability to,
uh,
do more than one thing at once.
I don't multi taxing dies,
want to look.
Yeah.
I don't even want to look.
My brain is like a messianic,
I don't even want to go in there.
It smells like a body.
But there are things you can do to bypass
the areas of damage to fix everything.
What can I do?
There are things you can do.
What can I do it?
Cause sometimes we damage,
we have a new product
that the more you talk,
the more I'm thinking,
yeah,
I got a problem.
We have evoked potential,
which is like an EEG of the
brain where it follows a,
you're sitting in front
of a computer reading,
you're looking at flashing lights,
you're looking at things and it causes
electrical patterns in the brain.
And there are quote normal
electrical patterns.
And then there's abnormal.
The abnormals correlate with different
areas of the brain because you've got
this net over your head
and it's sensing it.
It's being used in the
military right now by a doctor.
Uh,
David,
uh,
hauger crazy Dave,
right,
Dave.
But,
uh,
they're going to be sending
me one of the units,
so I'll have it in the office so we
can see how wonderful your brains from,
I'm scared.
I don't want to look in there.
Maybe,
but there are things we can do to,
to try and help it.
It's done brain transplant.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
I would,
I would like to see what my brain looks
like after three shots of Tequila.
You know,
that's the probably turns
to like the Batman logo.
Well yeah.
Would you like to see what your brain
looks like when it's completely fucked up?
Like if you could just,
it is right now around it and vodka
and just take a good look at it.
Absolutely.
Fmr.
I look different and be able to
tell if someone's intoxicated.
Well,
let's see.
The one that does the blood flow is the,
it follows the uh,
the red blood cells is the FM Ri.
Uh,
the electrical patterns would be
interesting to see because alcohol's an
anesthetic.
So you'll see drop off
in the electrical charge.
Is this,
is it possible that this technology will
evolve to the point where cops could
use it to tell if people are
fucked up when they're driving?
They just,
they don't even have to like
check your breath or any of that.
They just scan you with this little thing
real quick and they look at your brain
in 2,100 possibly.
Probably.
Right?
Yeah.
Right now it's a huge piece of equipment,
but so was the cell phone right?
Used to be a big suitcase.
You carry in your car,
you remember those tastes.
This is huge too.
But he got HTC.
Yeah.
See good smart man.
Go android.
That would put you,
keep your money on the winners.
Apple done fucked up.
Fucked up the cell phone game.
I Love Apple.
Don't get me wrong because apple people
go crazy when he started talking shit
about apple stock was up today.
It's great.
It's great company there.
They make awesome operating
systems and computers,
however their phones can suck it.
How about that?
I was with them for a long time and
people are tired of me talking about this.
I'm sorry you getting
that anger off your chest.
You need some couch time.
It's not off.
It's still there.
Okay.
Apple made me go android.
He made me leave with
a little skinny screen.
How sounds your bitches,
it's the uh,
DNA.
Yeah,
those are sweet phones.
Yeah.
There's so many cool
phones.
Just get,
I mean obviously the apple phones,
I'm just bullshitting around.
There's still great to
iPhones have the best camera.
I think if it never seen
a camera that's like,
it's easy to use.
And when you get like mega pixels,
you know,
some people say,
this has more of that
and a certain amount,
you just,
you just want it to look good,
right?
I mean,
when you get into like eight megapixels,
how big do you want that picture?
Like,
what are you doing with that thing?
If you want to make a poster,
yeah,
you're going to put a billboard,
a billboard,
and you need like a high megapixel,
but for the most part,
a little cell phone camera,
I'll do it for your kid to mix you.
Um,
you guys,
uh,
in,
in studying all this stuff exposed,
uh,
have really sort of a
dirty secret in the NFL,
in the world of boxing.
But for a long time people were able
to look at damage that was caused by,
uh,
you know,
athletes,
whether it's a box of being punched drunk,
and they looked at it sort
of almost with a willful,
willful ignorance.
They're like,
ah,
you know,
I guess he stayed around too long.
You know,
it's not like no one,
no one touches it.
No one described.
It becomes pugilistic
dementia and then you know,
that's it.
And the guy just fades away.
When you start talking about this
as a very real cause and effect,
um,
how much blow back is there from that?
Do you,
do people get upset at you for that?
They don't get upset at me.
They just don't talk to me.
Is that what happens?
Like when it comes to
like certain businesses,
like,
like football players or football
teams or hockey teams or something?
Something where people
take a lot of impact,
they get upset about these findings.
Uh,
of course they do because
the American pastime is what?
Flip sports?
Sports,
Football,
sports,
baseball.
So baseball,
they're afraid of changing
the way the game is played.
So look at you can't do,
what is that a rule 49 where
you can't do any side impact?
No side impact anymore.
There was a rule that came out through 49,
I don't remember.
Fucked up the youtube clips.
Yeah.
Cause those youtube clips where dudes
get hit from the side flying through the
air.
Oh,
that's such a brutal thing when you
get hit from the side by a giant man.
Yeah.
They're afraid that it's going to change
the way the game's played and it won't
be as exciting anymore.
It most certainly will.
You know,
it's like a glad,
I think we have a gladiator mentality.
We love seeing people getting hurt.
We love seeing,
you know,
the sports that are rough.
I mean I took my daughter when
she was 11 to a hockey game.
It was the,
uh,
New York.
Um,
uh,
what is it?
The Raider?
No,
the uh,
[inaudible] and uh,
islanders.
Jersey devils?
No,
no,
no.
The ones from New York,
but hockey team.
Anyway,
so she was cheering at 11 when they
were checking against the devil,
the Devil Jersey.
But there's a New York one
cause the islanders rangers,
it was the rangers.
It was a range of great game.
Absolutely great game.
And she was cheering when any,
someone was hit against the,
checked against the wall.
Right.
Unbelievable.
And that's what they do.
And then in the middle of the,
they pull off the
gloves and they gotten into the shoot.
Fuck out was unbelievable was
my first time at the rink.
Well,
the weirdest thing about hockey
fights is that it's really a salt.
Like you're allowed to assault each other.
Correct.
Cause you're not,
you're not wearing boxing gloves,
you're not wearing MMA gloves.
You're beating the shit out of each other.
Bare knuckle.
Like why is that legal?
I mean,
all they do is like,
they penalize you a little bit,
but you know what's going on.
Everybody knows it's happening.
The guy's not going to play
after he get fights anyway,
so he has to sit in a box for
a little while and cool off.
Whoa.
You really showed him
and he didn't show up.
Didn't show him shit,
man.
He just got in a fight.
He wants to take a break right now.
You guys just probably
broke his fucking hand.
People jump up and they're
cheering when the fights occur.
There's so crazy.
It's 48.
Yeah,
it's uh,
we like to watch people try
to win guilty of assault,
drinking a game.
A couple of years ago.
This guy,
he was known as a bad ass but got
charged and suspended for a long time.
Marty McSorley is his name.
Oh yeah,
sure.
Wow.
Holy Shit.
What's needed?
I think that guy was going to
do MMA at one point in time.
It sounds like a crazy man.
Yeah,
man.
It's just a very weird
how that's sort of like,
I mean,
if,
if baseball players go at it,
it's not,
you know,
that this becomes a big deal.
You know,
bench clean brawl.
That becomes a really big deal.
Baseball paid his fight on TV,
but hockey players are expected to,
it's par for the course.
It's just the game.
Yeah,
so it's fucking man's game.
That's it.
It's why Canadians are so powerful,
you know?
That's why I also,
they're so polite and their sport,
they could fucking,
just a fight to break out
the drop of a hat so loud.
You can't talk shit.
You know,
if you're on a basketball court
and you start talking shit,
you're most likely not going
to get punched in the face.
But if you're in a hockey rink,
it's most likely that you're
going to get punched in the face.
Say,
who was it?
Kelly,
Rudy and the fiber.
One winter they came left Canada
and came down to play here.
Five oh one winter.
Uh,
Kelly.
Rudy,
you ask him football questions.
I don't know.
It was hockey.
Oh,
I don't know.
Hockey,
basketball and football.
But a lot of Canadians we
thought you telling me,
I would think the Canadians,
uh,
absolutely would come down to the
states where there's a little bit more
civilized in the,
uh,
in the brawling.
Yeah.
But not as nice and the populace.
Huh?
You know,
you,
you have a brawling populous there.
That's a polite populace.
And which do we have?
Well,
we're not really broad.
We're talking shit.
Oh,
talk a lot of shit.
And then,
and in Canada and then we get separated.
Well,
let me go
and you know,
I mean,
this is very rarely a bench
clearing brawl in our sport.
Our sport is baseball,
right?
Or national sport.
Allegedly it's baseball,
even football.
I mean they hate each other
full clip while they're running,
but they rarely kick each other's asses.
It seems like you should totally be
allowed to kick each other's asses and
football,
but they don't allow it because it would
be too brutal because you look at the
size of some of these guys,
they took their helmets off and beat the
fuck out of each other in the middle of
the field and 80,000 people go,
ah,
it's too gangster.
Even for America.
So football players are
not allowed to fight.
That's a pretty interesting thing if you
really stop and think about like it's
just something we culturally
accept as being a rule,
but it makes no sense that hockey
players are allowed to fight.
But football players aren't.
That's so stupid.
That's a really dumb rule.
If,
if they're both playing
in the same country,
this is retarded.
It doesn't make any sense at all.
It's in the rules.
That's what football is going to do.
They're going to take out all these
crazy like side hits and put in brawls.
That was 48 it was uh,
cited side tackle.
Take that shit out and take the
helmet off and start throwing down.
If they added to that,
I'll put bode,
go through the fucking roof.
What happened in the beginning
with the use the leather,
what do they call it?
Little helmets.
Helmets.
Well those are good too because
you can't hit each other as hard.
It's really fucking dangerous.
It's hard to do and you realize you can't
run into each other full clip and use
your head like a battering
ram pads to patty.
There's actually less instances of
brain damage in rugby then there is an
American football.
Get that shit they used to wear.
That's hilarious.
It was a little funny,
silly pads,
but it'd be better if
people played like that.
They would get more hurt for sure.
But honestly it'd be better because they
would realize they can't play the game
that way.
The way they play it is completely unreal.
You had the girl,
how dare you?
Um,
they,
they would realize that you
can't just run into each other.
Like that's,
that's so preposterous that you think
you could just crash into each other and
everybody's going to be fun.
Like,
that's,
that's a recipe for danger.
That's a recipe for disaster just
running at each other full clip.
But if you force people in a
situation where they were bear head,
their head to head,
the idea of colliding with other
person's head does not seem that cool.
I'm just doing them.
They think they have some veneer of
protection by wearing the helmet.
But do you have less protection actually
when you're wearing a helmet because
your brain gets rattled around
more often cause you can take it.
That's the point.
Yeah.
You've got,
you know,
had a patient to,
uh,
who was driving a motorcycle up to four
or five at 70 miles an hour and he's
clipped by a car.
He goes up,
catapulted ends in the
ends up stopping his body,
ends up stopping in the fast lane.
Oh my God.
So I'm sitting there and
talking to the guy and I said,
so what happened next?
He says,
I woke up in the hospital.
I said,
so you had head trauma?
He said,
no.
I said,
why would you tell me you
didn't have head trauma?
He says his helmet wasn't broken.
Oh,
hilarious.
His helmet.
But he was in a coma for,
you know,
12 hours or whatever.
Woke up his legs up here.
He's got a broken leg,
six broken ribs,
uh,
harm,
clavicle broken.
And he ended up developing this incredible
anger and depression in the word is,
and hedonism,
which means no six,
he just didn't desire.
And a n and hedonism and Hayden SC and h,
e,
d I,
n I'm gonna use that from now on.
And he and hedonism.
So he developed this need
for sex and his testosterone,
when we tested him,
his testosterone was zero.
Whoa.
He was just shut down.
So
he's ready to die probably.
Well,
there's a lot of problems with not
having enough to stastrom depression,
kill yourself,
suicide,
and suicide.
We say zero,
but what was his actual level?
Probably 130 something
really in the literature,
they look at anything less
than 320 400 by some others.
Now when you see,
um,
the,
the science that goes behind,
um,
the,
uh,
the athletic commissions where they have
to do certain tests for drugs and do
certain tests for various
performance enhancing substances,
do you think that they should be
testing people's free testosterone?
They should be making sure that
people are healthy enough to compete
in 2006 I was on ESPN
to answer that question,
it's very difficult to give someone an
elixir of youth and say don't use it.
So if you give someone the
opportunity to use to stash on,
they're going to tend to abuse it,
right?
So it means monitoring them
before they play the game.
But look at football.
How old do you when you
start playing pop Warner?
I never played football
too smart for that shit.
So the bottom line is you start,
at what point do you start testing to
make sure the hormones are in a normal
balance?
When do you know as soon as you
possibly can to test them and then you,
every year you check them
to see if they're dropping.
Also,
you know,
because they've had,
um,
documented head to head injury or
they've been dinged and they've got,
you know,
their bell rung.
Um,
it's really,
that's the difficulty.
The commission's won't allow it,
you know,
look what happened to Lance Armstrong
goes aside from everything else.
He had a seminoma cancer of his testicle
and he was put on replacement levels of
testosterone and he was allowed to,
but then he got greedy and started
on a lot of other things started in
embellishing his levels.
Oh really?
Yeah,
that's what they say.
And you know,
a lot of the French Open people have,
uh,
some of them have been nailed
because they had tested a look.
What happened to James
Toney after fighting,
uh,
Jose,
um,
in Madison Square Garden,
they tested him and they found that his,
they said Deca and Angela
and Tacony date was,
which is a form of testosterone
was a 13 in the cutoff was nine.
But the testing that they do,
it doesn't detect the drug directly.
It's indirect.
So our testing technology is really bad.
It's still bad.
It's still bad,
but Olympic level testing is really good.
Right.
The Athletic Commission testing
is not quite at that level.
Is that what it is?
It's the difference between
urine testing and blood testing.
So it should be blood.
It should be blood.
I don't care.
You know,
the uh,
what is it?
The uh,
the leagues,
um,
uh,
the group,
the leagues,
uh,
Veda you talking about like it's the
ones that protect me and that's not the
anti-doping.
It's the leagues.
The ones who protect the
players from you invasion.
It's,
is that what it is?
The union players union?
Is it a player's union
told called players,
players union,
you know,
they protect the uh,
the player from invasion of privacy by
having it urine as opposed to blood.
The blood is more accurate.
Well that's one of the things
I was going to ask you.
I mean,
how,
how much of sports today really isn't
possible without some sort of performance
enhancing trucks.
I think every sport is possible without
any enhancement possible in the level
that you see it today.
Um,
yes.
I mean eating right.
I mean if you really want to get critical,
if you're eating really well,
that should be illegal
because it's enhancing,
right?
If you're taking vitamin supplements,
that's illegal because it's
enhanced protein powders.
Taking creatine,
you taking a,
you know,
a ride,
you're taking magnesium,
taking calcium,
all these things that have benefits.
You're taking resveratrol.
Well,
Arginine,
it all helps in the body,
so these things should be illegal.
If you follow that trend of thought,
you should not be doing that.
Anything that puts your capabilities
above what the normal level is,
but when you see something like
the Tour de France specifically,
I've heard that the numbers that they
achieve in the Tour de France are
literally impossible
unless you're taking drugs.
Blood doping is very common where they
take their butt out and put it back in.
A referral poet in used
to be very heavily used,
which stimulates your body to
produce more red blood cells.
Growth Hormone was great.
Provigil was great.
I mean,
I know because in reading some of the
documents that come to me to evaluate
cases,
you know,
a lot of things were being used to,
to enhance their capabilities.
Things like Dha,
Mark Maguire,
you know,
I only used interesting dial,
thou IOC,
the International Olympic Committee
doesn't allow for us to use or for the
client patients to use,
um,
DGA,
which comes from Mexican wild yams,
natural source,
vital hormones.
Don't let them use pregnenolone.
Don't let them use interesting Diane,
which is now off the market.
You can't have Anderson Dionn because
it only takes one chemical reaction to
make it into testosterone.
Uh,
terrorists tribulus
which is a plant based,
uh,
testosterone natural that's banned.
Tribulus has banned.
Tribulus has been such
tribulus was extremely mild.
It's still has the ability to
become testosterone terrorist.
Tribulus wow.
But isn't it like really bioavailability?
It's like very small,
isn't,
it?
Doesn't matter.
It does.
It gets on their list.
You look at their labs,
they've got,
um,
that's so crazy.
They've got a decongestants,
they have asthma medication.
You have to get a,
you know,
three cardinals and the pope to sign
off on you for asthma to use some of the
rescue inhalers because they can
give you a great energy surge.
Well,
I know some guys,
uh,
who are on Adderall,
they are prescribed Adderall.
They were told they have to
get off it to compete in a,
in an a.
So they have add and believe it or not,
there were articles that talk about
testosterone deficiency and add also women
with Anorexia Nervosa
who have failed a antidepressant therapy,
checking for thyroid
testosterone deficiency.
It's such a good point you were making
about that vitamins should be illegal,
that food should be illegal.
Healthy nutritional supplements should
be illegal because they all make you
perform better.
Correct.
So at what point in time are we going to
have something like what we're dealing
with now is like they're injecting
steroids and they're doing hormones,
but when they start getting into
genetic engineering of human beings,
like at what point in time our athletics
going to be even valid anymore.
If you're engineering super people as
they're going to come a point in time,
do you think,
I mean you're,
you're a scientist,
you're a doctor,
you're a smart dude when you're looking
at the future of human enhancement and
not just on a chemical
level or hormonal level,
like,
you know,
you're educated then,
but in,
you know,
when you,
when you look at it in
a technological level,
yeah.
I think these genetic
enhancements are for specific use.
Like military,
like if you want to be the hulk,
if you want to be the whole core,
you want to be captain America.
Could you imagine if
they decide to do that?
We develop different colors and entire
army of like hulk dudes that literally
are built like the hawk.
They're bulletproof.
They have fucking spider skin that's
mixed with a or the the spider silk.
They already developing that Spiderman.
Yeah.
Well they developing a,
um,
there's a,
uh,
artificial skin that they're trying to
create that's mixed with spider silk.
So it becomes literally bulletproof.
He'd have bulletproof skin.
Wow.
Giant,
huge hulk dudes.
You tell me some guys in Nebraska sitting
on a farm thinking about going over to
Iraq and kicking some ass and they go,
listen band.
I'm thinking about doing the hulk program,
man.
You know that Shit's permanent.
Yeah.
Hey man,
that's all.
I'm a hawk forever.
Whatever.
I'll be bulletproof.
Fuck it.
If they offered that to soldiers,
we're going to have a
real problem on our hands.
We're going to have an army of hawks
better do away with war.
Yes.
Do you think that would work?
That army of hawks would
everybody backing off?
It's like,
boy,
you haven't had a nuclear war since 1947.
Who hasn't?
We haven't.
We haven't ignored.
Yeah,
it wasn't it when it dropped the
bombs on Hiroshima and Nagasaki.
Was that 47?
No,
45.
Yeah,
Uh,
the Enola Gay.
The um,
if you stop wishing that
terrible thing to say,
he should have just kept it to yourself.
You're that guy.
Hey,
I have,
this is free for all.
It is certainly that I want
a straw with some paper wads.
I mean,
it's literally been the last
time anybody uses a nuclear bomb.
So,
and we all have them.
It's kind of,
maybe that's what's going on
with the genetic engineering.
We all become the hall.
Can everybody just stops.
That makes sense to fuck,
if that makes sense.
Do you,
do you worry though that you know,
there is going to come a point in time
where there's not going to be natural
humans or do you think it's exciting?
Do you,
do you think that it could be in some
way dangerous that we genetically
engineered human beings to live,
to be a thousand years old and
be able to jump over buildings?
Or do you think,
I mean,
what,
how do you feel about it?
Right.
I think that we've,
we've been modified already.
We've been modified and with what we eat,
we modify ourselves,
what we'd been injected with,
we've modified ourselves.
And I think that,
um,
there are,
let's see,
there's a,
a senator that's using stem cells
to generate new heart valves.
So we're going to have artificial,
natural,
artificial,
uh,
replacement organs.
So He'd go to the,
you know,
to the bank and you press a
new heart or your press a,
you know,
a longer schlong or whatever situation is,
uh,
we'll have medications to
make our heart work better.
Our lungs breathe better
to bring in more oxygen.
If we have any oxygen
left in our atmosphere,
it's dropped from 21% to I think or
22% down to 19% are oxygen level in our
atmosphere has dropped,
has dropped.
This is when,
um,
millions years it's dropped.
They were found,
they found oxygen trapped in ice that's
dated back millions of years and they
measured the amount of oxygen in it.
Wasn't that a part of the theory why
dinosaurs were so large and higher oxygen
concentration?
There's a higher oxygen concentration
and that they were able to move through
the atmosphere more easily because uh,
because their,
their considerable bulk,
it would have been not so much of
an impediment to movement with it.
I haven't read the atmosphere.
Yeah.
Again,
a theory that I fucking glanced over
then I'm spouting out as if I wrote the,
the paperwork myself.
So,
um,
that over the millions of years,
the oxygen level has been dropping.
And also,
you know,
we're killing down the
regenerating sources in the Amazon,
right,
right.
We're killing all the,
you know,
the trees and everything to build houses.
The Amazon thing,
it's really depressing.
Yeah.
I was listening to something on the way
over here where it was a discussion of
the Peruvian rain forest and their
collection of rubber in the early 19
hundreds,
and how this population of indigenous
people went from 45,000 down to 3,500 and
little or little over,
you know,
five,
six years.
They made these people go out and collect
rubber for them and they gave them a
quota that they had to reach in every
ounce that they were under that quota they
would take out in human flesh.
So they would chop peoples'
arms off or you know,
a pal put them on a scale,
like they slaughtered these people
and scared the fuck out of him.
But at the same sort of
techniques that Cortez used,
uh,
on the,
on the Aztecs way,
way back in the day.
So it's like literally
the same sort of practice,
but it happened in the early 19 hundreds
terrifying shed to the amount of like
evil shit that goes on in the rain forest.
They just shop it down,
make a profit,
chop it dies.
Plenty of it keep going until one day.
They're going to get to a point in time
when they realized they just hack down a
hundred million thousand year old trees
and it's going to take a thousand years
from the grow back and now we're fucked.
Yeah.
Fortunately people like Bono and share
had been buying up large blocks of a
territory in the Amazon to
preserve what you imagine.
If the earth has to be
saved by Bano together,
they save the earth.
Who will with Google?
They get together with Google
and they saved the earth.
They've been buying up the rain forest.
How cheap is the rain forest that
they could just buy it up like that?
Who's selling it to them?
Who owns that shit?
The government did.
They really all that shit.
It's all earth Earth's place.
You get the idea that people are just
going to keep doing that until they run
out of forest is absolutely terrifying
because it could happen and all the
medicinal things that we're losing because
they say there were species of plants
and animals,
insects and bugs and so forth
that had been decimated,
removed off the planet.
Extinct.
Yeah.
It's terrifying stuff.
Um,
you know about the Brazilian wandering
spider that they've discovered in the
Amazon?
No,
they're using wandering there,
uh,
doing research on which try to convert.
They're doing research on them to
try to convert it into a Viagra type
medication because the sting of the,
a wandering spider in Jack's,
that type of venom that causes you
to have an insanely painful erection.
And if you survive,
which a lot of people don't,
it's a very toxic spider.
But if you do survive,
your penis will be broken forever.
It'll never work again,
that it's somehow or another interacts
with your body's production of nitric
oxide and it just over floods your system
with it and your whole body goes into
this incredibly painful,
shocking state of muscle contraction,
including your CAC ruined.
Then it breaks like a fucking,
like a ballpark frank,
you know,
they plump when you cook them.
That's it.
That's going to happen.
Pop boom by just an evil spider.
So they're trying to convert this thing
into some sort of a truck viagara thing.
He just used to a sudafed.
Sudafed works to counter it.
Oh,
are you joking?
Nope.
What do you mean sudafed will counter
the effect of the Brazilian wandering at
spider of like Viagara if you're
telling me it's why I think is fiber,
the beaches,
Silas,
I don't think it works the same.
I mean obviously it's way more potent.
Yeah,
I'm still blocks the same thing.
Oh,
okay.
So,
and if you do that,
what do you take and how
much you take the Sudafed,
but what is the 30 milligrams
per tablet and it's two tablets,
but what is sudafed?
It's a decongestant.
It so reverses.
No,
no,
no.
I mean like is there a
chemical name for Sudafed?
F Adrin pseudo ephedra.
Ephedra
yeah.
So sudafed is like a speed,
so it causes the blood vessels to do this.
Fabric causes it to do this.
This causes of the,
wow.
So if you take that sort of speed
stuff after you take Viagra,
you're unbelievably painful reaction,
we'll go down.
Correct.
Yeah.
And it's called priapism.
Those poor bastards.
Yeah.
Sometimes they have to
get their penis is drained
out.
She why?
Why?
Cause they got crazy,
right?
They went to nine much too much.
You've got too crazy.
You got that 10 hour bone or something.
Nine.
So happy people are so stupid though.
Like if you give them the,
they get orders,
many cheeseburgers they want
and we'll fucking cheeseburgers.
If you just give him a bottle of this
crazy Brazilian wandering spider dick pill
and they think that shit home,
they're just going to suck
down the whole bottle.
People in nutty.
What'd you read that?
Scientific American.
I know it because it's in my art because
I'm very intuitive and I'm a healer and
I'm out there holding hands
with people and healing them.
I met a dude once,
told me he was a healer.
I walked away.
I was like,
we're not talking anymore,
dude.
You're not a fucking healer.
I'm a healer.
Basically.
Healer.
Have you ever had anybody try to heal you?
Mark Gordon,
no chick stories not settled down.
It's not that kind of show.
No,
it never had anyone tried
to heal me other than an MD.
Ah,
well then you're a smart man.
Trust and the bottle of Scotch.
Scotch doesn't work as long as you have
that glue to file on nearby to snap on
replenishment,
keeping my hormones,
I lost.
I was at the beginning of this whole
soldier and that I went on from being
diagnosed with a hormone deficiency.
I weighed 178 pounds,
21% body fat.
18 months later I was 214
pounds at nine to 10 pounds.
Nine to 10% body fat.
Wow.
Yeah,
because the thyroid deficiency was
helping me to gain all this weight and low
testosterone.
Do you think that the social stigma
that's attached to people cheating and
sports and steroids,
uh,
that keeps people from exploring
the idea of hormonal replacement,
but it seems to be a stigma behind it.
Like the idea of taking testosterone
or whatever the fuck you're taking.
Growth Hormone.
I think it's a medical issue where the,
the medical community as a whole has
taken this position of demonizing
testosterone and growth hormone and
all the hormone is also saying that,
you know,
they don't really need to be replaced,
but I've got what,
7,000 articles in my library on this
new book that I'm working on for head
trauma.
We're almost,
every single one has a positive statement
to make about how it improves mental
functioning,
how it improves,
uh,
depression,
anxiety and how it improves,
um,
personal interactions,
sexual drive,
physical stamina and so forth and so on.
And you get a number of articles that
come out to refute it because it just
doesn't fit in the social cultural
design that is being made for us.
And the articles that
come out to refute it.
You're talking about scientific art,
scientific articles.
What's the basis of their
argument against that?
Well,
if you really read close
their scientific study,
like the one that came out recently,
you probably saw it was in I think New
England Journal and medicine or the Jama
where it said that people who take
testosterone after they've had a
cardiovascular event,
heart attack or something,
or had a stint put in or
had open heart surgery,
that they die at a couple of percents
greater than the people who don't use it.
But if you looked at the study,
it was flawed study who's a
floss studied and it was um,
you know,
it was spun so that it would put more
fear into people about testosterone.
Do you think that that's done on purpose?
Do you think that this is
something like they say,
okay,
what is the angle where we can attack
testosterone while you have this angle?
You could say,
we have this one task and it could
be interpreted erroneously this way,
so let's do that and pretend
it's under good faith.
Correct.
Uh,
so they're academicians is one that I
interacted with at Ucla who were reviewed
and wrote a little article,
a little statement on how flawed
the study was and you know,
there are people coming up that people
can become famous for either developing
something or refuting
something that was developed.
You know,
just amount,
equal amount of people want to hear
that what you've developed is bullshit.
Just as mad as people.
There's an equal amount of people want
to hear that what you developed is
beneficial.
We don't want to hear that when
it comes to science and medicine.
We don't ever want to
believe there's ego involved.
We just don't.
We just,
we don't want to hear it.
Yeah,
right.
People,
he will fight that like they
fight the daddies and asshole.
If you found out the daddy
really was an asshole,
you know,
you're like,
God dammit.
I was holding out hope that
daddy wasn't an asshole.
Why is that?
Human Nature?
It's just human nature.
I think that companies would compete
knowing that the result would be that you,
you might take something effective out
of the market just because you're trying
to profit,
but people could benefit from it.
Yeah.
I know that there are congressional
laws behind growth hormone that makes it
illegal for any doctor to dispense
it for quote unquote anti aging.
We'll see.
You know,
why does it make it illegal for anyone
to dispense it for any reasons if it's
effective in enhancing health?
Correct.
But a colleague of mine who sees a
lot of people from the government in
Washington,
a lot of them are on growth hormone.
Of course they are the old
fucking creepy bastards.
Yeah.
It's like trying to live forever
and that shut everybody else down.
It's right.
It's like the con,
I mean,
the constitution states at
whatever congress passes,
they have to use two,
but they've exempted themselves from the,
uh,
the new health care laws.
Well,
there's just a lot of really weird rules.
Like there has to be something grossly
wrong with you for you to be prescribed
something that could be beneficial.
Like you know the story behind
provigil provigil first came along,
they were trying to make a,
a drug that enhances cognitive
function and the government was like,
no,
it's got to cure a disease.
And they went,
okay,
narcolepsy.
So the use of fucking narcolepsy,
but really what it is is a performance
enhancing drug for mental acuity,
but they keep it.
How crazy is that?
You can't say
that.
You can't say,
well,
we've got something that
makes you think better.
Are you stopping the
disease if you're not,
stop roid now will you have as legal?
Well,
they found a use for a
provigil and Nuvigil that's
outside of narcolepsy in it's
called work place fatigue and they gave
it what's called an ICD nine which is
the international classification
of disease coding.
Did I got a disease?
Yeah,
you've got,
you know,
because she worked so late.
Yes,
I have a disease the morning you
wake up and you're Fatina pro vigil.
How many scripts do you want?
A bit.
They'll say probably not
good to eat every day though,
right?
Tim?
Tim Ferriss was on the podcast
talking about that in fact.
And he said,
uh,
there's no biological
free lunch and correct.
That one seems you always have to
pay a little too wild to be safe.
Well new vigil cheaper and also smoother.
Really well a new vigils.
Actually the only shit that I've tried,
but uh,
it's a pretty shocking
how well that stuff works.
You almost are reluctant to talk about it.
How much is each pill?
I don't know.
Bob.
One,
one 50 milligrams.
All right.
How many,
I don't know.
It's like 20 to $25 a pill.
How much is [inaudible] I used to buy it,
you know,
cause we have a pharmacist at seven bucks.
One of the hard tech.
That's why he bought it.
Goddamn.
Absolutely.
Cause you had a pharmacist's license.
Why didn't,
why didn't you buy like birth
control pills while you're out it,
you didn't need those.
All right,
fellow,
I personally don't take
birth control pills.
Yeah,
I wouldn't either.
I think it's a bad idea.
Just let nature run its course.
Absolutely.
Get pregnant if you get pregnant.
Be the first.
Absolutely.
Um,
there's a,
there's a lot of a reluctance to
talk about the provigil and Nuvigil.
In fact,
I had a guy that's a,
from maps,
the multidisciplinary
psychedelic studies group didn't,
was,
it wasn't going to tell the,
like the audience that he was on
provigil while the show was on,
I was like,
why would you hide that?
It's like,
wow,
it just seems like he goes,
I flew here,
I was very tired.
I go,
it's a totally legitimate
reason to take it.
Like,
and it's not a bad thing.
You're obviously not,
it's not like you're drunk.
It's not like you're out of control.
You're functioning totally normally.
Like why be ashamed a
wasn't really ashamed,
but he was a bit concerned about the,
like,
like people would not take him seriously.
Oh,
the guy wasn't even sober
when he was on the show,
you know?
Oh,
that's what it is.
It's not,
you're doing scientific studies.
You're not just using it
as an excuse or a crutch.
So he was a little bit reluctant,
which I thought was really fascinating.
But it's not speed.
No,
no,
it's not at all.
It doesn't,
uh,
you know,
Warp your cognition,
your brain,
and you're not talking rapidly and
smoking cigarettes and tremors.
Yeah.
That can be a real issue with people.
Huh?
There's a lot of people that can do it.
I've seen people that have
had real problems with that
Adderall stuff where they
just get whacked out and
they know when it stopped.
What meth amphetamine,
Adderall is.
Methamphetamine.
Meth as,
and I hate to interrupt here,
but I have to pee.
I've,
but I want to keep the show going,
but I have to pee.
So Jamie,
please
talk to him about math.
Okay.
I'll take an Adderall.
Before I took it once and I wanted to
do some art projects and I'd never taken
it.
Friend gave it to me,
so I took a time release capsule,
hope.
I'm hoping that it would
just give me a little,
a little ding,
but it kept me up for two days.
It felt like I was poopy all day.
You know,
I restricted my own license,
my own prescribing license.
So I only do class three.
You know,
they have a class two class one,
you know,
heroin and quaaludes and
whatever else and two is um,
Adderall and I restricted my license.
I had so many people coming in thinking
that they can just get Adderall because
they're asking for it.
And I'm very,
very strict on how I dispense stuff.
I try not to dispense any medications
that I don't absolutely have to.
And I find that a lot of times that
when you correct the underlying hormone
deficiencies,
that the person gets better,
their cognition,
their energy level improves.
In fact,
in traumatic brain injury,
the number one symptom across
all the studies is fatigue.
And the minute you correct their hormones,
the fatigue is gone.
Wow.
I had,
uh,
you know,
initially a lot of people
coming in from the military,
the military likes using things like
Adderall and provigil in new vigil Nuvigil
vigilant pro vigil are,
they worked very well without
causing a lot of side effects.
But methamphetamine,
silliest thing that I have is
patients who come in on a multitude of
antipsychotic drugs I can't
do to presidents and so forth.
And because they're on so much to
control how bad they feel they have,
they're fatigued.
And so the doctors counters
it with Adderall and then
adds another drug because
they can't sleep at night called
Tressa don so they can sleep.
Here's the
question though,
is there ever going to come a point in
time where they can engineer the perfect
blend and you take something and
everything just works perfect?
I mean,
if we're enhancing our bodies in any
way with new chemicals and new medical
innovation,
do you think there's going to be,
I mean,
maybe this is just,
they're just not that good at it yet,
but one day then I have this one
pill and you take it and boom.
Yeah.
I don't think there'll be just one pill.
I think there'll be one pill for people
like you and one pill for people like me
because we're so genetically diverse and
biochemically diverse that it would be
nice to have one pill fits all,
but that's,
it's impossible.
It's impossible.
Right.
But do you feel
there'll be some sort of conditions like
that in the very near and foreseeable
future?
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
they're working on a,
I don't know if you remember,
I think it was star trek number two with
bones is walking through the hospital
in San Francisco and he hands a pill to
a woman who's getting ready to have or
renal kidney transplant and she takes
it and her kidneys start functioning
again.
We're going to be finding,
we're going to be finding medications
that turn the genetic code on for
different areas.
And that's why I was asking you about,
you know,
your genetics being tested.
Um,
we have products that are being studied
to turn on the genetic matrix and we
have others that stimulate
what they call Epi genetics.
It's not the genes,
but it's the things that control the
genes so you can influence the genes
directly and then you can influence the,
um,
the way the genes are
expressed and epigenetics.
So I think they'll find,
once they finalize the,
we have the map,
but we don't know where we're
going with genetic coding.
We know that that's ACD BBB bit,
but we don't know what that piece does.
Right.
We don't know.
You know,
we know the Br gene for breast cancer,
we know this thing for
that cancer and so forth.
And we're still trying to figure
out what that coding means,
what each piece of it means.
It's a piece of a puzzle and it's,
is it just because it's a new science and
it's just an incredibly complex puzzle
and,
but you,
you,
you're confident that eventually they'll
have eventually I'll have it in once
they learn how to master without
creating zombies or something.
Fuck Dude.
Yeah.
My kids got me into walking dead.
You're going to quit.
I already did last season.
You're going to get upset with yourself.
Well,
for watching the first season
was fucking spectacular.
The first season got everybody hooked
and it's just not like that anymore.
But when you see something like World
War z or you see something like that and
you,
do you worry that one day
there's going to be some sort of,
uh,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
You know,
you know,
the old saying don't
fuck with Mother Nature.
I never heard that.
I know you're New Jersey.
Oh fuck.
With Mother Nature Boston in New Jersey.
Yeah,
sure,
sure.
They didn't teach us
that in Boston either.
No,
don't feel broke.
You,
you're in parochial school,
Mother Nature was a content made it snow,
so it was,
okay.
Cool.
So what's going to ensure
exactly what parochial school is?
That's right.
You get parole.
It's a religious school.
Oh No,
we would boys Catholic
school for one year.
Oh,
sorry.
So what we did,
Loyola for two good Jewish boy.
Oh,
I got my graduate through regulations.
You made it through,
that's like,
Nah.
Absolutely.
So tell me,
um,
you know,
my fear is that when we start playing
with stuff we don't fully understand,
we're going to have a lot of
errors are a number of errors.
That's why up in aren't Arctica.
They have those little compounds.
So in case anything goes wrong,
it's in one little area.
Do you listen to the Alex Jones show?
No.
I know the FEMA camps and Antarctica.
No,
this is biotechnology council.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh,
so they have like in case the
shit hits the fan it cold areas,
you know,
it's not like a,
what was that from?
Um,
uh,
Jeez,
the Zombie movie.
Uh,
the first one that
started the whole series,
it was from a computer program,
computer game,
computer games.
I came out of computer game where
the a Zombie came out of a computer.
Now it back off.
Hey,
easy.
You don't want a shitty
at explaining things.
I just can't remember the name of
the program because I don't do games.
Right.
I play games.
Oh,
I know what you're talking about.
Meat,
Milos,
your bitch.
The evil resident evil that was a computer
game wasn't hot for surface that she
gets surface of the
Sun hot like Gary Hart,
like ruin your life.
Hot.
She's matured.
So anyway,
playing with,
tried to enhance the quality of life
and they came with a retro virus that
created the problem.
So if you look at probably walking dead,
it's for retro virus.
Well rage was the stuff that
they'd given the chimpanzee.
Oh look at that.
God Damn,
that's a woman.
Oh that shit makes me nervous.
But she doesn't like that.
Make me nervous,
man.
I know,
I'm too stupid to be
around someone like that.
Um,
so that was a,
in the movie,
28 days later,
that rage,
they had given it to these chimpanzees
and they had developed some sort of a
genetic disease,
some creation and artificial disease
and it got out and turned everybody into
savages.
That was a realistic scenario.
Well,
they're all potentially realistic when
we start screwing around with genetics.
Oh No.
It's all potential.
It's like,
you know,
when they were making the atomic bomb,
they,
they were afraid to light it off because
they thought that the ionosphere would
be ignited in the earth would burn.
Yeah.
But they said,
well,
let's see.
We'll see.
That's right.
Yeah.
That's the attitude they took.
Retro virus.
Uh,
you know,
it can make zombies out of everybody,
but we're not sure.
Let's see if it enhances them
before it makes him into a Zombie.
And it's not like we don't have
massive amounts of examples of terrible
situations when it comes to like animal
life and like as spiders and tigers in
Africa or tigers in Asia
and lions in Africa,
like there,
there's plenty of examples
of horrific hell's on earth.
You know,
if you happen to be in them and if
you're a an antelope and you're running
around and there was no lions and
all of sudden the line was there,
he'd be like,
fuck.
Well,
if we're running around cities and there's
no zombies and then one day there are
zombies that's gone off fucking suck.
And if it is one of those things where
they bite you and then you have it and
then you bite someone and they haven't
and it just spreads like in that fucking
World War z movie,
but,
but in walking dead,
what's the premise there that
we all already have it in us.
That premise is whack.
How did it happen that uh,
if I,
if I found out that I
was going to be a Zombie,
I'd shoot myself in the fucking head.
What am I going to do?
This band of fucking scallywags they're
trotting around the country with,
they're going to fix it.
They're not going to fix that badly.
What seasoned,
seasoned them billion just
fucks try watching it on
television and get broken up
every five minutes with a tie.
Dad Try watching that shit on TV?
No.
So you're worried about,
you're worried about genetic engineering?
Yeah.
Are you worried about it with foods?
Do you,
do you eat like totally organic
and no Gmos and all that shit?
What is it sir?
Brought you one.
What is it?
No Gmo.
What is it called?
Ratio ratio and a,
is it a protein bar?
24 grams of protein,
of net carbs
and four of a fiber.
No Gmo,
no artificial stuff in it.
What's the source of the protein?
Um,
come.
Hey,
what kind of fucking doctor you,
there's people out there
that are writing this down.
They're like c u m for
common used materials.
Soy.
This is soy.
So I thought so I made sure tits
grow maybe on you or try went here,
Jamie.
Wow.
Yeah.
The one that I didn't bring you was
the peanut butter and chocolate.
Now I thought soy for real.
I thought it made dudes go pregnant.
Make your estrogen grow.
No,
it has a light estrogens.
Genistein and Diastat has founded soil,
but you have to eat a whole bunch of that.
And that's not true
because Brian Red Band,
you didn't meet him.
He ate like three edit
mommies and he started crying.
It was watching was in Meg Ryan Film.
Oh yeah,
that'll do it every time.
And I'm on Ed.
A mommy will get you do.
I love that stuff.
Soya sauce.
That shit will get you.
Well,
it's a premise that I have is white and
I apologize to any of my Asian brothers
and sisters.
Something raise coming.
It's like saying I'm not a racist,
but this is a theory that I'm working on.
Why is it that Asian women have
smaller breasts in Western world women.
And the reason is that you
look at their soy intake.
Soy Is,
has these two chemicals,
Genistein and Diastat,
which can block the estrogen receptors
cause it's a weak estrogen receptor.
And the strongest generous
estrogen is Estradiol,
which causes breast tissue to grow.
So women who were in Asia,
who migrate to Hawaii have higher,
larger breasts,
higher estrodial functioning,
and the come to the United States even
higher because we got so much shit xeno
estrogens in our food.
That's why we talk with a
high voice with them times.
Wow.
We have a lot of hormones.
The federal government,
thank God just said we had to take out
antibiotics from some of our poultry.
We can no longer use in livestock.
Uh,
I think this year it starts,
or next year they can't use antibiotics
because our resistance to antibiotics is
possibly coming from the fact that a
lot of our meat has antibiotics in it so
that the animals are protected.
So that transfers when a,
when an animal gets 10
transcripts and you get the meat,
you get that antibiotic,
what do you think it reservoirs.
Reservoirs in the tissue.
Right.
And is it killed off by heat
or temperature or anything?
You'd have to really cook it.
Oh,
I'm gonna be really,
and that's all we do know.
So how do you like your,
sorry.
How do you like your meat?
I like venison.
Venison.
Yeah,
I'm on a goal.
My,
I have a goal in 2014 by the end of 2014
I want to be entirely game meat in my
house.
So you're going to go out and yes,
shooting things.
I shoved that thing over there.
You shut the skull.
No.
Shut the whole deer.
That's what's left.
I shot another one.
This goal then delicious.
It's,
it's a thousand times better than any
meat you'd ever get a supermarket.
And on top of that,
it's way healthier.
It tastes different.
When you eat it,
you feel
energized.
That shit is good for free range.
100%.
So that mother fucker was
hanging out in Montana,
in,
in the mountains.
We crept up on them and ganged him,
shot him.
I shot him with a bullet with,
um,
with a gun,
but I'm going to start.
Um,
she,
I'm shooting archery now.
I just started doing that to practice,
but I'm not,
I'm not even thinking about shooting an
animal until I got really fucking good.
I wounded a deer because my,
my,
uh,
scope was off because I had fallen
and when I fall on the right,
and I didn't know it was
so easy to throw it off,
even ask somebody if it could
it be thrown off if you fell.
He's like,
you'd have to fall really hard.
You could drop those
things and they're fine.
But it turns out that the
guy who installed my scope,
he didn't tighten it down very much.
So I wounded an animal.
It's a terrible feeling.
You chase after for two hours,
we look for it for two hours.
Um,
and then um,
we came to the conclusion that it's
probably wounded but not mortally wounded.
It's a fairy fucking
horrible depressing feeling.
You know,
especially when I put a shitload
of time into marksmanship.
I went to the range and shot 90 rounds
one day and then another at least 30 or
40 the next day before we went just
to get everything tightened down.
And I was doing it with that 300
win mag are really powerful rifle.
So I wanted to make sure that I was real.
So the first deer I killed,
perfect clean shot.
But the second one I missed it all
together and then I wounded and the second
attempt to hit it.
So you were at the range where
the full round with a full loads,
well,
this some rifle ranges,
you can go to their outdoors,
but their rifle ranges specifically and
they have targets set up at 400 yards.
700 yards is 900 yards,
100 yards,
200 yards,
the whole deal.
They have like fucking these little
metal things way out in the distance.
You can shoot,
hold the plate.
It's good.
You're going to a either a
crossbow or a longbow because uh,
probably won't be able to get the bullets.
Well,
you can use copper.
You can use copper.
Yeah.
That's what's going on now with like
hunting and a lot of ranches and things in
California,
they're trying to eliminate lead
because lead is really dangerous to the
environment,
to the animals that eat it.
Birds put it in their
gullet and they get sick.
Animals eat the birds.
People eat the animals that eat the birds.
Yeah.
I'm thinking more on the
lines of a homeland security
buying up the millions and
millions of rounds.
Is that true?
Yep.
That's an Alex Jones stuff.
Nope.
Homeland Security's buying up bullets.
What are they going to do with them?
They're buying the giveaway of a giveaway.
Look at if they buy them,
it means less for us to buy.
Yeah,
that's true.
But people are always gonna make bullets.
They're just going to help
out the bullet industry.
People make their own loads to do you
know that the US government used to return
the metal jackets to the United States,
be smelted down and regenerated four
bullets and it went into the general
population to do it.
You know where it's going now?
Where China Dammit,
I knew it was China.
China.
Now you've got aluminum jackets.
Yeah,
you've got aluminum jackets.
Now,
some of them with copper,
copper bullets.
Well,
some of them are still brass.
A lot of them are brass.
But either way.
I mean the,
um,
the federal government
trying to take away,
but what's at this point,
it seems pretty insane.
Unbelievable.
I was reading an article
where there was an Alec jobs.
What are they doing with all that?
Unless they plan on killing us.
They're young.
They're like the Internet.
These fucks.
We're going to shoot everybody's computer.
Go look at the,
I think it's called the
three Oh two or three 27,
which is the sniper rifle rounds.
Look at how many they bought.
Oh my God,
they're gonna Snipe us.
And this is for homeland security,
not for the military going
outside the United States.
Well that's depressing.
Maybe they know about an
alien invasion that we don't.
How about that?
Maybe it's already here.
Maybe that's why Obama is going gray.
They told him about the aliens.
It's like fuck God,
goddammit by them.
But just by the bullets,
by the bullets.
Did you ever set up snipers?
Everybody get practice.
The Youtube has something about,
um,
lizard eyes or the Lizard people.
I mean,
David Eick.
David.
Yeah.
David said,
come on the podcast.
I don't know,
uh,
if I could have them on and
not talk about the lizards,
but I don't think he wants to
talk about the lizards anymore.
What is he on now?
Um,
while he's got some actually interesting
valid points on corruption and you
know,
the Illuminati and you know,
just the way of the world.
But at one point in time,
he apparently allegedly was stating that
there was certain people that are in
control and positions of power in
the world that actually are lizards,
lizard people.
The reptilians,
the rough shape shifters or some shit.
And everybody was like,
uh,
you know,
now he doesn't say that anymore.
What happens is all this,
this information is to refute people
like David stating about the Reptilian
people and they really exist.
The Rep telling and people don't exist.
I'll tell you right now,
okay,
here's a bunch of shit
that's not real ready.
Go.
Um,
black people looking for big foot,
not real.
That doesn't exist.
Uh,
let me think.
What else does it,
real unicorns,
definitely not real.
Um,
big foot.
I got to go with not real.
I know.
I want to go with real.
Wish it was real.
This is,
um,
uh,
Pat Mcgee.
This is,
this is the guy who made the
Werewolf in the front yard.
He's,
uh,
he's going to make a movie,
on big foot and these crowd sourcing
it and he's building all of the,
uh,
the parts in his lab here.
And he made this video
and sent it to me today.
It's fucking sick.
It's if they wanted to do like one
of those Patterson Gimlin movies now,
boy,
they could freak people the fuck out.
Cause the artificial Bigfoot's that they
create now or are amazing the work that
they've done in,
in special effects.
Let's look at this.
They're doing this one hair at a time.
This is incredible.
The face looks to duck like
until they put the skin over it.
Yeah.
No,
it's incredible.
Look at this
so you won't
get Tbi.
It's got a lot of protection on it.
That is so wild.
It's neat.
Yeah.
Wow.
And that's what it looks
like when it's all done.
God Damn.
That's awesome.
Ah,
that's,
that seems like something that would
be in like a modern version of twilight
zone.
God Damn.
That is amazing for will rage.
That looks really cool.
As long as it's all shadowy,
they make a big mistake when they try to
make monster movies and make everything
like real crystal clear,
like come on stupid.
You got to keep shit in the shadows.
The,
your CGI is not that good.
Stop showing off.
Stop showing off with your
fucking fake big foot,
big foot royal.
Why don't even think it's real.
Well,
um,
I,
I don't not think it's real.
Um,
I went to the Pacific northwest actually
looking for bigfoot for the Scifi show
that I did and I'm,
I'm convinced that I talked to people
that believe that they saw something.
Uh,
what it actually is,
who knows?
But the reality of the Pacific northwest
is the density of the forest is
incredible.
It's hard to imagine if
you've never visited there.
I had an idea in my head
what it would be like,
but the,
the enormity of it all
and how insignificant tiny
I felt when I was in it.
That place is like a magical rain forest.
It's a true rain forest.
It's gorgeous.
And the inside is filled with bright
green moss and the trees are filled with
bright green leaves and it's only sunny
like every other day or something like
that.
Most of the time it's just raining
constantly and it's fucking lush man.
Like,
like a dense box of Q tips
is how I described like the,
the trees there.
And you realize once you're there like,
Oh,
who knows what's out here?
They might be anything out here,
but the idea that it's gone this long
with all these people looking for it and
no one's brought back a body,
nobody came across,
nobody shot it.
Nobody.
Most likely bullshit.
So you're basically saying because
they haven't had more evidence,
there's not enough evidence,
um,
that is every evidence
that they've ever found,
whether it's DNA testing,
whether it's a,
that's me and Duncan in the woods.
Look at us.
We were looking around,
we were squatting with John and Steve.
Um,
every piece of evidence
that they've ever found,
it's turned out to be bear shit.
Or this was a fascinating thing we found
at tp of trees that were ripped out of
the ground.
And then like put into position,
you know,
and some of them like we're like,
well literally ripped
out by the root ball.
Like the amount of strength that someone
would have to have to do that and then
do it that way.
So that was it.
That was another piece there was was it
was a broke off branch that was broke
off in the middle of the tree and these
guys were convinced a big foot did that.
Cool guys.
Man,
they had a cool attitude too because
their attitude was even if there's no big
foot,
they're still out camping,
enjoying nature and like
indulging in this no footprints.
They do find footprints.
But the issue with this area
of the Pacific northwest,
is that what you,
you see these guys walking on right here.
That stuff is so soft.
It's so incredibly dense.
With pine needles they said that there's
between five and six feet of compressed
pine needles under your feet and then
eventually becomes dirt and you know,
breaks down.
But it's so soft.
You're walking on everything.
It's like a big sponge
so you can't get fleet.
Cool.
It's really fucking cool though.
You see elk everywhere.
They're just running through
that place like rats.
And this woman who was,
uh,
one of the people that lives up there
in the mountain up in Mount Rainier,
she was the most convincing because she
just didn't seem like a bullshit artist
at all.
And she said she saw these elk running
and she was looking to see what they were
running from.
She was on a hike and she turned,
she's like,
oh,
there's a gorilla.
Oh my God,
that's big foot.
And she said,
it's the only time she ever saw it.
She never saw it since.
But she said she saw this thing,
she sought for about five or six seconds,
maybe a little bit more
and move in between trees.
You know,
just trying to estimate
while she's freaking out.
And she realized,
Holy Shit,
I saw a Sasquatch.
Maybe it was a bear that got
hit in the face with a rock.
You know what else it was?
The Canadian Indians,
the native Indians of Canada,
they have lots of stories on,
not just,
they have lots of stories.
They have over 200 different names for it.
This is interesting because it doesn't
mean that people haven't made up,
you know,
mythical animals and things in the past.
They certainly have,
and if you wanted to think about some
old man that lives in the woods and you
know some why you don't and you never
know what the fucks are on any corner when
you're in the woods,
especially back then and the Indian days,
you know,
they,
it's probably a good cautionary tale
to pretend there's some giant wild man
living in the woods that much larger
than you and it doesn't give a fuck and
hides from cameras.
You know?
It seems like it's a good
thing to tell your kids.
What was that movie,
Henry and the Henderson that
was most likely real then?
That was about,
it was going to say,
I believed that move.
I think that it's possible that there
could be an animal that we haven't
discovered that it's that animal.
Ooh,
that's a tough one.
It's such a dense vegetation up.
It's so big.
That's the problem.
This thing's giant.
It would need to eat a lot of food.
They would need to be fucking eating
constantly cause anyone sent a set up
either thermal sensors,
they set up everything and trembles the,
they've set up a game.
Cameras.
No one's ever caught a
big foot on a game camera.
When you stop and think about how
much shit gets caught on game cameras,
that's quite shocking because
they're really prevalent now.
It's like the same argument about
Ufos and cell phone cameras.
Well,
why didn't you take a picture?
I didn't have a camera.
Everybody has a camera now,
but there's still not like this
massive influx of UFO videos that are
legitimate.
There's still all horse shit.
So as they,
these game cameras become more and more
prevalent in the woods where people go
out hunting or they'd go outside,
outside seeing or looking for animals.
You know,
they're a recent,
in the northwest,
there was a,
or Midwest,
there was a sighting with
lights that were just hovering.
Hundreds of people took pictures of it.
Oh,
you're talking about,
um,
the,
the Phoenix Lights,
the Phoenix Lights.
I think that was in the late nineties.
I would want something more.
I think more recent really.
Maybe,
maybe Phoenix lights were,
um,
I believe it was the nineties gas bubbles.
I talked to people that when
I go to Phoenix all the time,
in fact,
I'm going to Phoenix this weekend,
this weekend,
these gentlemen stand up live with
the lovely and talented Thompson era.
But um,
I've talked to people that were there
when that happened and they were pretty
convincing,
man.
They,
they,
they believe they saw something,
but what it was like,
who knows?
They all described like a bunch of people
describe this giant like triangle that
was flying silently through
the sky and you know,
maybe,
or that could have been
just fucking freaking out
area 51 area 51 I think that's what it is.
Area 51 they launched,
they just said,
let's just freak out.
Phoenix.
How do you think we went through such a
rapid technological advancement since 19
late fifties?
You think it's because the aliens,
where do you get a really analogy?
You think you're a full on nutter,
you the anti vaccine.
We believe in aliens.
You believe that alien technology
has not alone in the universe?
Hey,
you say that I feel really alone.
You do sometimes again,
I'll give you a hug later.
Yeah.
So you believe that,
that it's actually
possible that someone has,
uh,
somehow or another cat people from the
information that human beings have been
visited and that we have actually
received technology from aliens.
The possibilities there.
Wow.
What would you say a percentage?
I agree with you.
The possibility is there.
I don't know what the percentage would be.
You know,
what is the one that keeps
me sane percentage versus,
you know,
crazy.
Hmm.
What's the percentage there is no,
there's no,
well,
I,
I honestly,
I mean all bullshit aside,
putting myself out there,
not,
not worried about what I look like,
you know,
because if you start talking about aliens,
you do a Vegan idiot.
Let's just accept that.
I submit to that.
Um,
I don't think we look
like regular monkeys.
I think we looked at Fred.
It's weird.
It's weird how we look different and
I know that there's been a bunch of
different stages of us along the way.
I get all that,
but man,
they seem like they were pretty recent.
Those fucking things seemed pretty recent.
And when they find out that people's
brain size doubled over a period of 2
million years and there's
no logical explanation,
I go,
oh,
what,
wait a minute.
How do we,
how do we start talking?
Had all that happen.
What is it possible that something
came down and fucked with us?
The same way we fuck with virtually
everything that we find in the wild.
And is that possible when we inject
fucking lipstick and the rabbits to see if
it kills him?
You know why no one,
yeah,
Bat Shit.
That's what they use for lipstick.
Used to be what it was used.
I think they still using
it in some manufacturing
or the most horrible story about bad shit.
These guys in Africa,
these scientists were
doing some sort of a,
um,
uh,
exploration on bats.
And there was a one particular,
a cave where these bats came out at
night and they came out in massive,
massive numbers.
So these guys set up a,
and they stayed out there to catch it.
So as the bats are flying out of the cave,
they would,
uh,
take the shots of them.
They didn't realize or think that the
bats shit when they come out of the cage.
So the cave rather.
So the bats,
these millions upon millions of bats,
all shit on them and they got deathly
ill and were dead within weeks.
Both men died of just horrible diseases,
horrible like hemorrhagic viruses.
Their eyes were fucking bleeding.
I mean,
like really terrible ways to die.
They got introduced to all sorts of
terrible pathogens from bat shit.
Bats are shifting so much on them,
like inches of shit.
So they were covered in this horrible
toxic shit from these flying monsters.
Sounds like a great
premise for a movie team.
People,
Ladies,
gentlemen,
I'm on team people.
Baths can go fuck themselves.
That's wrong.
Shitting on scientists.
Meanwhile that those guys could
have been saved with an umbrella.
How about that,
you know,
an umbrella Newark and
a map of the territory.
Why didn't they,
uh,
set something up in advance to,
like what's,
let's see what happens first.
Let's not be there.
Can we set a remote camera?
I mean,
what if something weird
happens like Dracula,
it comes out with them.
Hmm.
Healed.
That's a terrible way to die though,
man.
Death by bat.
Shit.
Viruses.
Even worse.
Yeah.
There's a lot of ugly ones,
Huh?
Ebola.
Yeah.
Did they have that one?
Their control.
How do you get Ebola?
It was manufactured.
Really.
You think so?
I think a lot of the
virus in manufacturing,
there was a documentary on the HIV.
Freaked me out.
That's a,
that's how my uncle who
was a homophobe uses it.
Yeah.
They all got the HIV.
Mm hmm.
I was fucking with the HIV,
you know,
these guys,
the HIV,
it was a documentary on,
on HIV,
no,
HIV.
Trying to go through the history of how
it developed and the way that story was
told was there was a French,
you know,
one of the largest vaccine
companies as a French company.
It starts with an M and,
a.
They were in desire year and at a camp
trying to grow a smallpox vaccine on a
culture and they couldn't do it.
So what they ended up doing,
because it would die,
it wouldn't sustain it.
So they ended up getting Simeon,
which is monkey liver.
Oh or monkey kidney.
Oh.
And the groove.
The virus,
the smallpox virus on it.
And what happened was they believe that
the monkeys virus crossed over from
monkey to human and in this vaccine.
And who was the first
case that was documented?
This French guy that was came
to the United States was the
plague,
the typhoid Mary,
you know,
who brought it over to the states.
So a French guy came over
here and so he's patient
zero in the United States.
How many days like that guy?
Like a million.
Don't know if it was gay.
It wasn't Gary while he was,
he was,
yeah,
it was.
I'm trying to find this documentary.
It was like two hours long
and it was just awesome.
Is it substantiated like as a disputed,
has there been,
as it been debunked?
Do you know?
That would be the first thing
that I would want would happen
most the people that
were doing the project,
the program.
Do you what's called a no,
it was
maybe almost 10 years ago
that it was on and it's a,
it was a documentary on
smallpox and smallpox,
HIV and um,
they went to the Louis Pasture Institute
in Paris and there was supposedly a
sample of the original culture that they,
if they would go through
that original culture,
they would see the Simian virus
becoming a mutating over to being human.
Whoa.
The Simeon a s I Siv.
He was Simeon immune virus.
And then when it's a
humans human immuno virus,
HIV.
Wow.
Yeah.
Someone gave me a book on experiments on
of viral and in it talks about HIV and
Ebola.
I'll give you the book if you want it.
So how come that's like hidden knowledge,
knowledge about that.
It's hiding in plain sight.
It's hiding in plain sight,
but nobody talks about it.
No one talks about,
no one reads it because there was that
old Sam Kinison joke about aids coming
from a monkey.
And then Dave Chappelle had an even better
job actually just like talking about
how hard it was to fuck a monkey.
Cause Somebody fucking monkey.
You're telling me someone fucked a monkey?
I don't believe it
has such a great premise.
Just thinking about that.
It's so true.
It makes you laugh.
Just thinking about a guy trying to
hold onto a monkey was biting him.
Spider Monkey.
I don't know if I buy that.
I feel like if that was the truth
that that would be out there.
Okay.
What is it?
Let's,
let's try to do a Google search on
it and see if there's a debunking.
Since you haven't done your due diligence,
sir,
before you come out with us with his
outlandish claim was the smallpox virus?
Yeah,
it was based.
It was in Zaire French
company fringe group,
and I don't know if it was origin of aids.
Okay.
There's a smallpox virus,
HIV documentary.
Here it goes.
What year?
Um,
AIDS linked to smallpox vaccine.
Let's see.
I think it's called the origin.
Oh,
the world's most dangerous virus.
Hmm.
No,
that's not it.
I was seeing a Nova documentary on it,
but I don't know if that's the one.
Yeah,
it seems like there's quite a few.
Um,
it's hard to tell,
right?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Yep.
But sitting there watching
and I was just glued to it.
I usually don't watch tovs knife if I
can avoid it except for walking dead,
which now going to stop since you said
you have this,
well,
I don't,
I'm just kidding.
I'll still watch it.
I'm a bitch.
I'm just upset that they're
beating me up my brain up.
Yeah.
There's an article in here from the
London Times about smallpox vaccine
triggered aids virus and aids epidemic
may have been triggered by the mass
vaccination campaign,
which eradicated smallpox.
Whoa.
The World Health Organization,
which masterminded a 13 year campaign,
is studying the new scientific evidence,
suggesting that the immunizations with
immunization with smallpox vaccine,
I n I a vaccine and Nah,
I can fix India.
Facsia awakened the unsuspected dormant
human immune deficient virus infection
in this program.
They said it,
it was,
um,
it was a term for it.
It crossed species.
So is that they're positive spin on it,
that it awakened the unsuspected dormant
human immunodeficiency virus instead of
created it.
It created it.
Simian virus stay viruses
and monkeys stay in monkeys.
Human viruses stay in humans,
but when it crosses the species,
which is a very difficult
thing to do unless it mutates.
So what happened in this premise of this
documentary quote that I saw was that
by culturing the smallpox vaccine,
smallpox in on Simeon monkey kidneys,
that whatever they were feeding,
it allowed it to cross the genetics.
I see.
Got It.
So much like swine flu and
things along those lines,
costs cross from cattle
and livestock and birds.
They cross over to paypal.
They crossover that.
That's a real issue,
isn't it?
That's
that's why they're manipulating or
people manipulating and genetic code and
mixing things together.
It scares me.
Yeah,
it seems like it should
and it seems like a,
I mean,
I joke around about it,
but when people are concerned about that,
they get late labeled into that category.
Oh,
you're one of those guys,
Huh?
Listen,
if it wasn't for GMO food,
it wasn't for golden rice,
it'd be a billion less
people on the earth.
People will always tell you that
the golden rice is a big one.
They always bring that one up,
whatever.
Maybe the earth could use
a billion less people.
That's why we have diseases
and why we have wars.
Do you really think that wars are for that
did wipe out people on purpose,
like the Illuminati gets together
and they work out a deal?
I think it,
it's not specifically only about
eliminating people and population control,
but I think there's,
if you look at the,
the best financing war machinery
war is incredible financing.
How much money have we spent in in Iraq?
$50 that would be,
yeah,
it's,
it's a bargain when you really
find out what the numbers,
so
that'd be like the Super
Kohlberg character.
A guy just makes up numbers,
did the truth about Afghanistan,
Iraq,
$50 that's it.
Everything else was donated,
donated from churches and good people.
They wanted us to go over there
and kill those fucks and let's see.
All the oil fields in Iraq were given to
what Gulf and Exxon is a gift for their
humanitarian service
to the military there.
I buy that now.
It's totally logical.
And then the $20 billion that was sitting
in the bank from all the oil being
sold worldwide world war was going on.
And why didn't they use that for the war?
Because we were busy.
We had shit to do.
We need money here.
Fighting for freedom.
Yeah.
Don't worry about you.
Worry about your own shit.
Worry about us.
We're taking care of you.
It wasn't for us.
You wouldn't even be getting any freedom.
Yeah.
Well it's a great argument.
As long as you're not going
around creating the AIDS virus.
Yeah.
A few good men,
Huh?
Creating the AIDS virus
in your spare time.
Um,
is it possible that other diseases you
think that had been accidentally created
stupidity.
Stupidity.
Is that a disease or is
that just a function?
It's a function of punk,
human and being allowed to be stupid here.
We give people the option to be stupid.
They will often be on your
cell phone all the time.
Okay.
Play stupid games.
I don't do those.
Watch television.
I have discipline dumbing down,
not me buddy.
I'm up at six doing kettlebells.
6:00 PM I get out.
I do like to get up early
every now and then just to say,
boy,
this sucks.
I don't want to do this anymore.
I'm done.
Kids get up,
they get up early.
I'm just kidding.
I know you were.
I take them to school
when I take him to school,
uh,
most of the time my wife does,
but when I do take them to school,
I actually run with the five year
old does just like running track.
We'll run laps and shit.
They have a whole thing they're doing to
try to introduce kids to exercise in an
early age and they make it fun and
exciting for them and cut out all the crap
and their diet.
That's a problem,
man.
I see some of the things her
little friends have and uh,
you know,
a little five year olds are
eaten Gish hint for lunch.
Like God,
it's just like,
just things that they think their kid
will eat and they're worried that the kid
won't eat healthy food.
Like your kids lead healthy food,
man,
you just got gotta you know,
train them.
Yeah,
we'll give him the healthy
food and then give him,
you know,
a little bit of delicious
treats as a reward.
You know,
give them something because they did
their homework because they let him have a
little every now and then,
don't make it a big deal that I'm,
have a little cake,
let him have a little ice cream.
But you got to make sure
that they understand that in
order for their body to be
healthy and not get disease isn't
sound like it's a communication thing.
And some people don't
even want to do that work.
They're like,
it's fucking kid's not listening.
Give them a cake.
Give him the cake.
Give him the candy.
I'm tired of him crying and I'm okay.
You little fuck.
It's terrible.
It's to pass away.
It's just weak people,
you know?
And it's also people that aren't,
are on concerned about their own diets.
You know,
I know many people who never give any
consideration whatsoever to the fuel that
they put inside their body.
They just don't,
they don't think about vegetables,
they don't think about Fido.
You don't think about minerals and
they don't think about being hydrated.
They treat their body
like it's some rental car.
They just pour in shit down into like,
oh well it drove run on premium.
Yes.
Would also run on human shit.
It,
well,
well I'm just going to back my ass
up to this fucking hoes and shit.
Then my car,
you know,
that's what people would do if they could,
that's what they choose.
How they treat their body.
You could have a guy who
works all day and you know,
forces his body to do,
you know,
very stressful computations and he's
running on coffee and cheeseburgers from
Mcdonald's and candy and a fucking
protein bar that's filled with GMO corn.
That's all possible.
And you,
you wonder what's,
what the fuck is wrong with us as a
society when we can't get our mental shit
together.
Why bodies are rotting apart.
Dr. Gordon and you got
it rotting all part.
Where's my kroner Renee?
I cronut cronut the cronut.
What's a krone?
So croissant donut.
Oh,
krona.
Well,
you're very specific.
How would you even expect?
Expect me to know that.
If you said like a chocolate croissant.
No,
I would say I've had those.
This is a calm that where they have
lines waiting for the people to eat them.
Oh,
is it some famous thing or
something relatively do is,
yeah.
People line up to buy a
special type of donut guy.
We were so stupid.
People are so dumb.
Yeah.
You should've seen the line of black and
whites line the black and white people.
Is that what you're saying?
Oh Jesus Christ.
I don't know what you're saying.
You mean cops so the cops are lining
up to get these special donuts.
That's what you're saying.
Did you just tell it a
cop donut joke on my show?
Absolute dairy.
You doctor.
That's like me showing up
in your office with Voodoo.
I compensate by line.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Where is it?
New York is New York,
New York.
They're all in line to get a donut.
I fucking hate krone.
Everyone in that line.
I hate all of you there.
What two blue are all of the problem.
You fuck heads.
You are all crazy and ridiculous.
That's a mile long line
for a fucking doughnut.
How dare you when you see it
doesn't fuck with Krispy Kreme.
I don't care what anybody says.
It can't.
Krispy Kreme doughnuts when
they're right out of the oven,
does not a thing that can
tastes better than that.
It doesn't get better than that.
Where's the Krispy Kreme plays all over?
Santa Monica is the closest to here,
so there's Burbank.
Yeah,
but that's closed down.
I heard a lot of them did.
That's just cause of communism.
Ah,
that's what,
that's what it is.
Socialism,
try to keep the man down.
They need to expand.
They should have Krispy Kremes everywhere.
If you want to do something decadent
that's horrible for your body.
Why are you fucking around?
You need just a couple of Krispy Kremes.
You'll feel like shit after they're down,
but when they're going down
it will be goddamned Gloria.
I'm going to find some cronuts
and bring them to you when they,
when you eat one of those maple ones.
Do you know those warm maple ones?
You hear Bon Jovi singing
when you bite into it.
Shop,
you feel it,
you feel it in your bones.
You toes tingle,
you know,
you've given yourself cancer and you care.
You don't care.
It's a million milligrams of sugar.
1 million.
That's what I heard when
I saw a documentary.
1 million.
It's exactly the amount of sugar
that you can eat and not die.
That's what's in a box of
Krispy Kreme donut burger.
Oh,
that's ridiculous.
I've had bacon on mine.
I don't need that.
So it's a croissant donut mix
with a cheeseburger and um,
they smash it all together and put
powdered sugar on the top of why we hate
ourselves.
Fucking humans hate ourselves.
We're crazy.
That looks almost edible.
Do you allow yourself cheat days?
I know you're really
healthy for the most part.
No,
I don't have cheat days.
Do you have cheat meals?
I don't have cheat meals.
Do you have cheat desserts?
Nope.
Do you eat dessert?
Yup.
So you just eat it.
I just need it.
It's not a cheat.
It's part of the entire diet and
nutrition desert is a part of nutrition.
Tell me more apples with peanut.
What should I eat?
Oh,
you fucked.
Bolstered up isn't that is not dessert.
How dare you fucking dare you.
The grades on this guy.
How about that is not
man yogurt with a sigh.
He dark chocolate.
[inaudible] Osi.
He sie
peanuts and walnuts and pine nuts.
I've got a better idea.
How about a hot fudge Sundae?
Fuck,
I want a Brownie.
How about a Brownie with hot fudge on it?
Just read Katari 31 flavors.
I'm there.
Yeah,
so you eat those too.
I'll lead it.
But for the most part you try to reward
yourself with delicious things that are
actually new trends or things.
I might have a carbonated
drink once a month.
My friend Mike Dolce,
he's a,
I'm a nutritionist to
a lot of MMA fighters.
Helps them with their
diet and losing weight.
He doesn't believe in cheat days,
but he believes in reward meals.
Like you will reward
yourself to cheat meal.
It's just semantics for your hard work.
It's semantics.
Come on.
Why you got to call it,
why you gotta be near this cheat is
a negative and reward as a positive.
Exactly.
That's what he's a glass
half full kind of a guy.
I got it.
So I said,
so you can't find it for him.
He tried to break him
down there he is like,
oh,
that's the rock of the
rocks cheat days or epic.
Look at the size of that guy.
What is he eating?
Look at the size of that guy who
gives a fuck what he's eating.
He is Goddamn he huge.
He used to be a normal size like
big athlete but now he's fucking,
that guy is obsessed with working out too.
If you go to is if you're a
guy that likes to work out,
subscribe to the rocks,
Twitter and is his Twitter
and his Instagram or epic
because this guy will fly
into a city at like four
o'clock in the morning.
It'd be at the gym at six taking pictures,
tweeting and going crazy.
He just believes in
like constant hard work,
doing things that are difficult,
making yourself work out when you don't
want to and he's very strictly as die
except one day.
And that one day he has these fucking
epic cheat days where he takes photos of
stacks of donuts and
literally like jugs of milk,
like five gallon jugs of
milk and fucking giant
savage.
See,
to me,
that's like injecting yourself with a
thousand milligrams of testosterone in one
day as opposed to taking
20 milligrams every day.
Well,
I have,
I think he's mentally,
uh,
he's probably a crazy person.
Look at the size of them.
That's what you used to look like.
That's what it looks like now.
Wow.
Yeah,
he's giant.
I think he is a crazy person as
I think he's a in the good way.
I think he's a crazy person for a success.
You know,
he's a crazy person for achievement,
so he's just getting crazy for pumping
his body up into this ultimate super
athlete machine.
She,
I feel small.
Do you should feel small next to
him were both producing estrogen.
That's speak for yourself.
We both produce androgen for
standing next to the rock.
I met the guy,
trust me,
he's too big.
Still look at the size of that guy.
I mean that's a big fella.
Jeez.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
So if you look at for inspiration,
follow him on Instagram.
Um,
for the average guy,
um,
what,
what should the average person do if
they want to find out that something,
what's going on with their hormones,
where their hormone levels are,
what's the,
what's the steps that they
should take to find out?
Well,
we have an automated system
to make it easier if they go,
if they have a traumatic brain injury
or have had a traumatic brain injury,
and I'll just interject this,
if they're with the military or would
the police department or with the NFL
retiree we have,
I have three grants to pay for.
There are two thousand one hundred two
thousand two hundred dollars laboratory
testing.
He'll be paid for by a grant.
So they go to the website and they fill
out an application and within 12 to 24
hours,
someone in our office calls to
just confirm a couple of things.
And send them out about
20 pages worth of intake.
Any your,
um,
experience a lot of the people that
are experiencing real bad results from
traumatic brain injury,
oftentimes it's hormonally related,
correct?
Well,
you know,
I take care of what's
called mild to moderate.
These are people who might not have
lost consciousness in the mild.
Some of them might have a little
amnesia that lasts for less than 12,
24 hours.
Is it shocking for you how
easy it is to damage the brain?
Unbelievable.
Uh,
one case that just finished a gentleman
was rear ended at five to seven miles an
hour and ended up getting
traumatic brain injury so crazy.
Uh,
the brain sits,
you know,
in an envelope with fluid supporting it.
But there's the front part of the inside
of the brain and the backside at the
front pilot called the sweet,
annoyed,
plateaued.
It's a sharp area that all
you have to do is stop short.
You just have to shake your head,
shaking baby,
working on a pneumatic drill or
a pneumatic hammer or a knee,
a skiing moguls where you're up and
down or doing waterskiing where you're
hitting the waves and
you're bouncing up and down.
Wow.
That's how simple it is.
And we've taken it for granted that
the brain is impervious to damage.
So waterskiing could
give you brain damage.
Correct.
It's repetitive.
It's a form of repetitive.
Think of it this way.
You're standing there in the rank
and someone's just tapping you.
Hey Bro,
I know,
move on.
Right.
Slick Brunel,
Whitaker and his PR,
your rope a dope.
Anyway,
if you were getting hit lightly,
the accumulate,
the damage accumulates over time.
That totally makes sense.
Um,
there was,
uh,
there's been quite a
few actually guys who,
uh,
realized after a while that they
couldn't take punishment anymore,
that their brain just was simply not
allowing them to take those shots.
They'd get hit and their
body would just give out.
Right.
When you see that,
is that like just like hurting
a knee or hurting your back,
you're more likely to hurt it again?
Like if you,
if you hurt your knee and you,
you tear your meniscus,
it's,
there's a high probability of
you entering that knee again,
that knee has now been weakened,
correct.
Is that how the brain is as well?
Well,
it's,
the brain is just awesome.
There is connections from the
different lobes of the brain,
from the left to right,
the front to the back.
And there are connections
that can be torn,
called sharing.
And if you tear enough of them,
what happens is you
lose cognitive ability,
mental ability,
your personality changes.
And over a period of time you might
have this slow progression towards
depression or slow progression
towards memory loss or fatigue.
So
it happens over a long period of time.
There's a 30 year pro pro spective study,
which means they had people who had head
trauma and they followed them for 30
years.
That's creepy.
48 I'll follow my man.
25 fucking years.
I am your shadows to fall on me,
man.
So they found something like
48% of the people had a,
a psychological problem.
28% of them had depression
and 8% paranoia.
Drug abuse is a very
large thing that happens.
And I'm starting to look at
kids who are addicted to drugs,
whether or not it's a methamphetamine,
heroin,
uh,
Oxycontin,
narcotics or whatever,
that they have a history of having had
head trauma and they've just been looking
for medication,
drugs to help them feel better.
They're looking for their own cure.
You know,
if you look back in the add beginning of,
uh,
attention deficit disorder,
you had kids looking for,
they felt a hyper,
so they would take downers.
Well,
what happens is called paradoxical.
If they take it down or they get spit up,
they take an upper that get spent down.
That's what Ritalin is,
right?
That's what methamphetamine
or the Adderall is.
So it's an Adderall they prescribed
for people who are too hyper.
Correct.
It doesn't make sense,
but it's called paradoxical.
It does the opposite
effect of what it should.
And it's only in certain people,
like people with attention
deficit disorder,
a Ahdh hyper activity.
And um,
you know,
we're looking,
they're looking for,
for drugs,
alcohol.
A guy that came from Boston.
I'll tell you a Boston story.
Uh,
Jr came from Boston rugby
player five head Traumas,
three loss of consciousness
in one hospitalization.
Pussy.
Yeah.
Really?
And between the ages of 23,
23 and 35,
he became an alcoholic at
35 be crashed and burned.
And he was institutionalized and he was
put on three antidepressants and he flew
out from Boston.
We did our testing and even though
he's on three antidepressants,
he was still depressed.
It's Jesus Christ still depressed.
And this is one of the hallmarks
of traumatic brain injury.
It's called treatment
resistant depression.
We're finding that people who are put
onto one medication and it doesn't work or
two does work or get shifted
around because they stop working.
You need to look at the hormones,
we need to look at hormones and we
put him on 60 milligrams that to,
because his level of
testosterone was extremely low,
60 milligrams of testosterone a week,
six months later,
his psychiatrist,
he had to get a new psychiatrist,
took him off his drugs.
He's back in Boston.
He's investment banking now.
When,
when,
when a guy has an issue,
if there's something or a cow or anybody,
Kara called girl Gal,
you're kind of creepy,
what do you want to call it?
Weird.
So that's like when,
when you definitely don't
wanna fuck female Gal,
she's a great old Gal.
Um,
if someone has had,
if someone has had enough of an impact
on their brain that they have to seek
exogenous,
is that the word?
Yup.
Exogenous hormones to,
to fix whatever problem they have.
What,
what would you do if that person was
still engaging in the very activities that
caused them to,
to have this,
this issue with their body?
Absolutely.
Pull them.
So in MMA,
so an MMA,
when you see these people
getting testosterone,
which is,
you know,
what,
what do you think about that?
Well,
hopefully the doctor has
done the relationship of his
activity MMA and he's done
the workup,
which includes,
you know,
laboratory testing as well as the
radiological evaluation to see what the
damages and if you see,
you know,
areas that are very classical
for damaged scarring,
Exxon,
no scarring,
brain scarring,
the old believed that he had,
well,
if they had a bleed,
they would have been
in the hospital mostly.
Hopefully not everybody.
It would.
That's what you would use to decide
whether or not the person who is at risk.
I've got a case right now from the
entertainment world where it's a stunt man
who is,
he's been through a lot of
traumas and his last trauma,
beginning of last year,
I left him depressed.
He was in a coma and left
him depressed and so forth.
And within five weeks he's better.
And the question became,
he's good enough to go back to work,
but you don't want him to go back to work,
right?
Because if he gets banged around again,
you lose everything you've gained.
Oh boy.
So this is why people don't
want to talk about it.
You've got some great football
players who've been dinged.
You don't want to go
do that test that says,
I'm sorry,
but uh,
you can no longer play football.
You're 25 years of age and
you've got scars in the brain,
which means you're at
high risk for developing,
you know,
the CTE.
Do you remember when that a
football player died because
he fell out of the back
of his truck?
His girlfriend was
driving away in his truck.
They did a brain scan on him after he
died and they did his autopsy and they out
had the brain of like an
Alzheimer's efficient CTE.
And here's another thing,
and it was young,
right?
He was young.
I didn't bring my presentation.
I do like what?
Let's fuck.
Sorry.
Come on man.
I didn't know you had PPTs
and me professionally,
I have lava lamps here
and rock salt lights,
nice color and everything.
I figured you would be prepared.
So what they found is with head trauma,
you will develop Alzheimer's Disease 19
Times faster than if you don't have head
trauma.
Jesus Christ 19 times.
And I was in Vegas giving a lecture on
traumatic brain injury and there was a
doc talking specifically about head trauma
and Alzheimer's and his documentation
was irrefutably supportive
of the relationship and
they know it so they don't
want to tell someone,
look at keep playing football likelihood
is you'll retire and you'll develop
Alzheimer's and does die at 54.
How old was a hundred waters?
I don't know.
Young guys,
he was young.
All the guys that have died.
Who was the last one was San
Diego who died at 24 years of age.
This,
you know,
I dunno.
It's depressing.
So in your opinion,
uh,
as an expert on the subject,
when a guy gets to a point where he
needs testosterone because of this,
they really shouldn't be engaging in
whatever caused them to lose their ability
to produce testosterone.
That would be a late case scenario.
So someone getting a testosterone use
exemption for mixed martial arts in your
opinion would be a bad idea?
Correct.
Especially if it was due to head to
positive findings of damage by DT MRI or
functional MRI or Mri.
So that's the thing
about when someone has a,
a testosterone use exemption,
they don't have to specify the
cause of testosterone being low.
They just find that it is
and then supplement it.
How could they find what it is?
I mean,
are there,
what are the various reasons
why people besides aging,
why people don't have good testosterone,
female?
No.
Females have high levels.
Um,
you know,
having had to stick your with trauma,
cooking your testicles,
I cook them break
talking about greater than 105 days
or a lawyer put the onions in it.
So,
um,
head trauma.
It's the regulatory
mechanism in the brain.
And then you have peripheral,
which is the testicle itself.
Any kind of damage,
infections,
mumps,
talking about mumps,
mumps can cause the
testicles to stop working.
Okay.
So just the viral infection,
you can get loss of testicular function.
But in someone who is MMA,
I would have to really
think long and hard about,
hmm,
he has testosterone deficiency has been
an MMA for six years and he's had a,
you know,
five documented loss of consciousness.
A,
he's beaten over the head.
Who knows how many times in training.
Correct?
Yeah.
I have a guide that was
in training and got Kod.
Yeah.
That happens all the time.
And then guys wind up fighting just a
couple of weeks later and they can't take
a punch.
Right.
And you know,
we've seen it many times,
um,
is uh,
Marvin has been,
Travis Luder is a famous,
a fight where a Travis Luder knocked out
Marvin Neiman with a punch that looked
like a barely connected.
And it turned out that we had heard
that Marvin Marvin Eastman had been in
training camp and had gotten hurt and
training camp got knocked out maybe twice,
at least once.
And he's a great fighter
to really tough guy.
So it didn't make any
sense that he could took,
couldn't take a punch like that.
It was one of those weird cases.
What we're starting to
see on the Internet,
which might be a backdoor
type of self analysis,
are these cognitive testing programs.
There's one called impact,
which is out of um,
uh,
Pennsylvania with the doctor who is
the neurosurgeon for the Pittsburgh
Steelers.
A duck.
Sure.
Watch this.
Travis Luter hits him with his punch.
It's crazy.
And he goes down like
he got shot by a sniper.
It's a really crazy to watch this.
I mean,
he,
he like,
I mean he kind of connected but
he's totally out it totally out.
Like watch the punch again.
I mean,
you're pretty good shot,
but man,
it seemed like he was
on the very end of it.
It just didn't seem like it
should have that kind of impact.
We,
Travis does hit really hard,
very strong guy.
But then when you found out that he,
I mean he definitely would
have got hurt by that punch,
but going out like that seems unusual.
And I think it was because,
uh,
they said that see it like grazes him,
they said Marvin had,
uh,
gotten KOD and training
that happened also to,
um,
uh,
Forrest Griffin before
he fought Anderson Silva.
He had apparently had
gotten KOD and training.
Uh,
I think he said twice too.
Yeah.
And you sure.
And they're additive so
you don't kill me right.
Through their cumulative additive,
cumulative.
And it just gets easier.
I hate to have to correct
you in front of those people,
but sometimes you just fuck up,
dude.
Hey,
I think you're so smart.
Only you're the one who
thinks I'm so smart.
Do you think I spent
five days a week reading?
Because I know so little.
Yeah.
Well that's very,
very humble of you.
You're also a martial artists.
You've,
uh,
so this is a,
something that's not
like a alien to you've,
uh,
it's martial arts for a long time.
Yeah.
I did taekwondo sector,
read black belt on the cover of martial
arts magazine cover of a magazine,
son throwing side kicks on bitches with
my master of young you foot in my mouth.
Did it tastes good?
No,
it did.
Yeah,
I would imagine it's
waiting for you to answer.
You answered.
Correct.
Um,
if people want to know more about
there's that,
they're fascinated by it.
If they think perhaps they
might have an issue themselves.
Uh,
what is the weapon?
The website is TB.
I Med med legal,
l e g a l.com.
That's very hard to remember.
Yeah.
Tbi Med,
legal.com.
And it has,
uh,
about a hundred articles that
are abstracted very shortly.
You put a link up for,
for people that are
listening to this podcast.
You crafty bastard.
You just so professional.
You make me sad.
I do.
Yeah.
Cause I'm not that.
Go ahead and click it.
What happens when you
click that it exploded.
Oh,
thank you.
Joe Rogan did,
but that's not,
did you sign up for this under
my name or something like that?
Oh,
it just says that.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's information which goes through it.
Oh,
I see.
Um,
so if people are curious about their own
issue or 30 people have already clicked
it,
but wait,
now it's gonna get crazy.
This is just,
Ustream has probably,
I don't know what
percentage of the actual,
very small percentage.
Most people tend to listen to this
while they're doing other things.
Like they listened to it on the subway
or in the gym on the bike or whatever.
Um,
the amount of people
that actually watch us,
but the people that actually
watch us at the most critical,
crazed nerds,
not in a good way.
And a good way.
If you give me a hug,
give a fuck,
leave Tbi,
medical,
middly,
Med legal,
Tbi,
med legal,
and they could find out all about it.
And um,
is there anything else you would want
to promote or let people know about what
here I'm not,
the only thing I really want to promote
is the knowledge that there's this
incredible association
between head trauma,
hormone deficiency and
change in personality.
And when you correct the
underlying deficiency,
you see people blossom to end.
I'll say that we have a 32 year
post traumatic brain injury.
Cal 32 years.
She cracked her carotid in an auto
accident and partial stroke on the right
side.
32 years she's lived with
the incapacitation or
suboptimal life on a multitude
of drugs.
12 weeks after starting her program,
she's off of everything.
Whoa.
And she started losing weight.
She's 53 years of age.
She started losing weight.
Uh,
she swimming again.
I was a swimmer in med school and,
uh,
in,
in Undergrad.
And so she started back swimming
and she's back in school.
Uh,
her life is just energized.
She feels phenomenal.
And they write their story to me and
there'll be eventually posted on the
website.
We have you know about 571 271
patients with testosterone.
Then total about 500 plus people.
I've been doing this a 10 years,
just specifically traumatic brain,
but overall 18 years
with hormone replacement,
not knowing for those first years
that there was so many people,
which meant eight years,
first eight years that there are so many
people with traumatic to efficiency.
The brain is very delicate.
People choose wisely,
be safe,
be careful and get your
dome checked out right.
Dot.
Absolutely dumb checked out folks.
Thank you everybody.
Thanks for tuning in and the the website.
One more time.
His TBI MED,
legal.com go and joy.
Thank you.
It was like,
you very much appreciate it brother.
Always good.
Always cool to see you.
I knew you'd
beGood@thisrogandotting.com go there,
get yourself some ting you freaks and uh,
go to hover,
hover.com use the code word
powerful for today's episode.
Also thanks to [inaudible]
Dot com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha Brain shroom tech,
sport in new mood.
All stuff that I will give to
the good doctor to have him try.
I said the good doctor,
I'm on automatically
think a hunters Thompson.
Sorry,
I don't automatically think
you're fucked up on drugs.
I apologize for that connection.
Uh,
on it.com o n n I t use a codeword
Rogan saved yourself 10% off.
I got a lot of stuff coming up folks.
Next week I have doctor Rick Strassman
is going to be here on Monday.
And then Dan Dodi and Remy Warren,
Remy Warren is a,
a guy who goes so low hunting
and documents them on a
show called Solo hunters.
This motherfucker is out in Africa hunting
with a bow and Arrow by himself and
some cameras.
It's amazing stuff.
Uh,
Brian Dunning's favorites,
a favorite and famous both skeptic
comes in on a Tuesday the 14th,
and then on the 17th.
My brother Steve Rinella is going to be
here again and we're going to discuss
all kinds of groovy shit.
All right?
We love the fuck out of you people and
we appreciate the fuck out of people,
so appreciate yourself to give
yourself a big hug from me.
See,
Monday.